ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALES
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A UORUM
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA
POWER QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BRIAN BURKE CALDERON CORREO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LOUIS LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY INA MULLIN SUCI THIS
AREA. NGUYEN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS CORK
CORK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
C. R. TO SMITH STONE TEEN
BALLOT AREAS THE ABUJA VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY IS IN SESSION PLEASE
COME TO THE FLOOR. SO WE MAY
PROCEED WITH THE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE HOUSE.
THANK.
MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WAY. WE ASK THAT. OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAZE PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YES SIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. GRATEROL
GRACE. YOU HAVE CALLED US TO
ETERNAL GLORY. HELP US TO BE
EVER MINDFUL OF OUR FINAL
DESTINY AND OUR PURPOSE WHILE
HERE ON EARTH. YOU NOT ONLY
CALL EACH OF US BY NAME. YOU
DRAW US TO YOURSELF BY OUR
INNATE DESIRE TO KNOW THE TRUTH.
TO SEEK WHAT IS GOOD TO TAKE
DELIGHT IN BEAUTY AND TO HUNGER.
AND TO HAVE A HUNGER FOR
LASTING JUSTICE. COMPLETE YOUR
WORK IN US AND THROUGH US. THAT
WE MAY PROVE OURSELVES PUBLIC
SERVANTS. AND BRING THE STATE
TO YOUR HONOR. AND GIVE YOUR
GLORY NOW AND FOREVER. WE OFFER
OUR CONDOLENCES. FROM ALL OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE ON
THIS FLOOR THIS MORNING. AND
EVERYONE HERE AT THE STATE OF
THE STATE CAPITOL. TO MR RENDON
MISTER SPEAKER. OF THE PASSING
OF HIS MOTHER LAST NIGHT. OUR
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY. AND
MAY GOD BE WITH YOU IN THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. I MEAN. THANK
YOU MARIA SIR YES OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE WAS CALLED. STORMING FOR
THE SALUTE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. YEAH. THANK YOU
MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAIRMAN SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY
MET AT NINE AM WE ARE WE'RE
BACK ABOUT QUE AN ASSISTANT
RESPECTFUL TO FOR THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK SUPERCOPA
DANCE READING FROM DAVID WOMAN
READING WILL CALL THE ROLL CALL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATION
TIME PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY TODAY'S
ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
DENNIS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS COOPER QUICK
SILVA RUBIO RAMOS AND CHOI TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
ROLE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO. I
AM REVISING MY REFERRAL S. B.
THREE ELEVEN HUESO TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
THE BILL WILL BE ORDERED BACK
TO THIRD READING.
MEMBERS
SIMILAR TO YESTERDAY WE'RE
GOING TO START ON. SENATE THIRD
READING. WE ARE A BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE
SENATE THIRD READING. SENATE
THIRD THIS IS FILE ITEM. FIFTY
SIX. SENATE BILL FOR THIRTY SIX.
SAYS MR BIGELOW. AND THE
COVERAGE. SENATE BILL FOR
THIRTY SIX BY CENTER DALLY AN
ACT RELATING TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. MISTER BIGELOW. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT SB FOUR THREE SIX ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR DOLLY AND
MYSELF THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
NEVADA STUDENTS IN THE TAHOE
BASIN TO CONTINUE PAYING IN
STATE TUITION AT LAKE TAHOE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AYE ARJUN
AYE VOTE AND HOPE FONG THOUGHTS
AND SINCE YOUR THOUGHTS FOR
THOSE FOLKS WERE AFFECTED BY
THE FIRE UP IN THEIR AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MISTER BIGELOW SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL. DESIRABLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE IT IS AT A VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I'D FOUR NINE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
FIFTY SEVEN THROUGH SIXTY. PASS
AND RETAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE. SB. SEVEN TWENTY
ONE. OKAY COOKERY SENATE BILL
SEVEN TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR
HUESO AND OTHERS IN ATLANTA
CALIFORNIA FORMER DAY MISTER
EDUARDO GARCIA YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUES-
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWO ONE IS A
BILL THAT WOULD DESIGNATE
AUGUST TWENTY SIXTH AS
CALIFORNIA FORMER DAY ONE OF
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
FARMWORKERS AND WHAT THEY
PROVIDE TO THE STATE TO THE
NATION AND TO THE WORLD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CSE
NOTIFICATION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL
CLOSER ALL TIED UP AS FIFTY SIX
DOES ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. SIXTY TWO.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO S.
B. TWO ELEVEN CORKERY. SENATE
BILL TWO ELEVEN BY SENATOR
UMBERG ACCOLADE TO ATTORNEYS MR
STONE YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOUNG
MAN THERE'S A BETTER PARTY
MISTER SO THESE ARE AMENDMENTS
AMENDMENTS CORRECT THESE ARE
AMENDMENTS ON SB TWO ELEVEN
CLICK READ WITH AMENDMENTS
CITADEL TO ELEVEN WITH A
MINUTES BY SOME MEMBER STONE MR
STONE ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MET MEMBERS
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE THIS IS
THE ANNUAL BAR DUES BILL THE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE BAR DUES
AS WELL AS THE ENHANCE. THE
BARS OBLIGATION FOR ATTORNEY
DISCIPLINE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
FAMOUS DOWN WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY THE S. HAVEN'T. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED BILLS
OUT PRINT OF ON FILE. ASCERTAIN
A PROBLEM SIXTY THREE PASS
TEMPORARILY ON SIXTY FOUR. PASS
RETAIN ON SIXTY FIVE AND SIXTY
SIX. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
SEVEN S. B. SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
CORKERY WITH IMMENSE SENATE
BILL SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT WITH A
WOMEN'S BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. MYSTERY OF US ON
THE MAMMOTHS AND THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT US IN CHAPTER IN
AMENDMENTS TO SENATE BILL SEVEN
TO EIGHT BY OUR SENATE.
MAJORITY LEADER RESPECT LACK
RESPECT THAT'S WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK OF ISRAEL'S
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED.
BILLS UP THE PRINTER BACK ON
FILE. FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT
THROUGH SEVENTY PASS AND RETAIN.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY. ON THE BALLOT IN
SEVENTY ONE PASS RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM SEVENTY TWO. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTY THREE. SB FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR SEPARATE SENATE-
FORTY FOUR BY CENTER ARCHULETA
AND ACCORDING TO HOME
INSPECTIONS DR WEBER YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR ARCH ALETTA. SB FORTY
FOUR CLARIFIES THAT A LICENSED
PLUMBING CONTRACTOR CAN MAKE
REPAIRS TO A SEWER SEWER
LATERAL PIPE THAT THEY HAVE
INSPECTED EVEN IF THEY OR THEIR
COMPANY HAS PERFORMED A HOME
INSPECTION ON THE SAME
PROPERTY. SB FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
PROTECT CONSUMERS WHILE
ALLOWING THEM TO CHOOSE A
LICENSED PLUMBING CONTRACTOR TO
CONDUCT A SEWER LATERAL
INSPECTION AND MAKE ANY REPAIRS
NEEDED EVEN IF THE PLUMBERS
COMPANY HAS PERFORMED A HOME
INSPECTION ON THE SAME
PROPERTY. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON SB FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THAT WERE. SEE NOTE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CORPORAL. IS THAT A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THAT A VOTE
TO. WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
ICE FORTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS.
SEVENTY FOUR. THROUGH EIGHTY
FOUR PASS AND RETAIN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE SB FOUR
HUNDRED FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
RENDON'S. SENATE BILL FOUR
HUNDRED WITH LIMITS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US MS RIVAS ON
THE MAMMOTHS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THESE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE THOSE PROPOSED. BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO REDUCE
COSTS IN ADDITION TO CHAP
DURING AMENDMENTS TO ONE OF MY
BILLS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
RIVAS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE I. SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINTER
BACK ON FILE. FILE ITEMS EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
HOUSE. AND RETAIN WE ARE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY. ON FILE
ITEM. EIGHTY NINE. ASCERTAIN A
PROBLEM NINETY. THIS BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM NINETY ONE SB
EIGHTY THREE CORPORATE. SENATE
BILL EIGHTY THREE BY CENTER
ALLEN AND OTHERS AND I
POLITICAL SO RESOURCES. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS EMAIL BUT THANK
YOU MR THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
NUMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
CENTER ALLEN'S SB EIGHTY THREE
WHICH OFFERS AN INNOVATIVE AND
ELEGANT SOLUTION TO THE LOOMING
CLIMATE DISASTER AT SEA LEVEL
RISE AT THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH A REVOLVING LOAN FUND
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO THAT
THEY CAN BUY PROPERTIES THAT
WILL BE THREATENED FROM SEA
LEVEL RISE ALLOWING THE OWNERS
TO SELL THE HOUSE STILL HAS
VALUE. THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN
THEN RENT OUT THE PROPERTY
REPAYING THE LOAN AND EARNING
REVENUE THEN WHEN THE PROPERTY
IS AT RISK OF FLOODING FROM
RISING SEA LEVELS THE HOUSE CAN
BE DEMOLISHED OR RELOCATED
WITHOUT LOCAL RESIDENTS FOR TAX
PAYERS BEARING THAT COST AT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS
OF SEA LEVEL RISE BOUNCING VERY
LIMITED BUDGETS AND FEW GOOD
OPTIONS FOR THE NEEDS OF
HOMEOWNERS ON AS I SAID THIS
BILL PRESENTS A REALLY ELEGANT
SOLUTION TO ONE OF. OUR THE
PROFOUND CHALLENGES THAT WILL
CONFRONT OUR STATE IN THE
DECADES TO COME I PROUD TO BE A
CO AUTHOR ON THIS MEASURE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
FACT. THANK YOU IS PICTURED. C.
NOTICED. FOR ON THE ITEM THE
CLUB. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY ONE. NO
SEVEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS NINETY TWO THROUGH NINETY
FOUR PASS. AND RETAIN THIS IS
FILE I'M NINETY FIVE SB TWO
FIFTEEN CORPORATION. SENATE
BILL TWO FIFTEEN BY CENTER
LEYVA AND OTHERS AND THAT
RELATING TO EVIDENCE. MR CHIU
YOU MAIL BUT- THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES SB TWO
FIFTEEN WOULD CREATE A SURVIVAL
PORTAL IN CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
RAPE KIT TRACKING SYSTEM THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT. FORENSIC
EVIDENCE TRACKING SAFETY
DATABASE TO ALLOW SURVIVORS OF
RAPE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT TO
PRIVATELY AND SECURELY TRACK
THE STATUS OF THEIR SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS. BY
ENACTING THIS BILL CALIFORNIA
WILL ENSURE THAT SURVIVORS HAVE
ACCESS TO CRUCIAL AND TIMELY
INFORMATION REGARDING THEIR
CASES ON THEIR OWN TERMS.
THIRTY THREE STATES ALREADY
HAVE A SEXUAL ASSAULT KIT
TRACKING SYSTEM EITHER IN USE
OR IN PROCESS BUT ALL THESE
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY ONE THAT
DOES NOT HAVE AN ONLINE PORTAL
FOR VICTIMS TO CHECK THEIR CASE
STATUS AND LOCATIONS. THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE WILL EMPOWER
SURVIVORS ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
HELP THEM CONTINUE IN THEIR
HEALING PROCESS AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MR CHIU. SEINER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM. THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. RESERVE THAT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. YEAH.
CARDWELL. CLOSER ALL THE TIME
ABOUT ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THE HACER
QUE ABOUT A NINETY SIX PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM NINETY
SEVEN. THIS BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM NINETY EIGHT. SB TWO FORTY
SEVEN OPERATE. SENATE BILL TWO
FORTY SEVEN BY CENTER EGGMAN
AND OTHERS AND I'M CALLING TO
RARE DISEASES MITCHELL OF ANY
MAIL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SB TWO FORTY SEVEN
WHICH WILL CREATE A RARE
DISEASE ADVISORY COUNCIL IN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY GIVING A MUCH
NEEDED VOICE TO THE ESTIMATED
ONE IN TEN RARE DISEASE
PATIENTS LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS LEVINE. C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CORPORAL. WHAT IS THERE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS. A
RETAIN A FILE ITEM NINETY NINE.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE HUNDRED. WE ARE FILE ITEM
ONE ONE SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT
SEPARATE. SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
EIGHT BY SAID ARCHULETA AND
OTHERS AN APPLE IN THE PARKS
AND RECREATION. MISS GARCIA.
YOUR MAILBOX. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'M HERE PERCENT SB TWO
SIXTY EIGHT WHICH WILL RE
AUTHORIZED THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE LOWER THING GIVE A VALLEY
RIVER RECREATION AND PARK
DISTRICT. AND MAKES THE VOTING
STRUCTURE FOR THE LOWER ELLIE
RIVER PARK DISTRICT MORE
EQUITABLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. THAT VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. TO RESERVE A.
WELL CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP
BUT SIXTY ONE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS ONE
OR TWO THROUGH ONE OH FOUR.
PASS AND RETAIN THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE OH FIVE SB THREE
THIRTY SIX FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS. SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY SIX WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON MISTER
GIBSON ON MMS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO. PRESENT AMENDMENTS FOR
SB THREE THREE SIX ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR LET'S ALL VOTE- THESE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE
OF THE VIDEO AT THE REQUEST OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO CONFORM WITH
EXISTING PRACTICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT
OF PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM ONE OH SIX. PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE OF SEVEN
AND ONE AWAY THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE SB THREE
SIXTY SIX. CORKERY. THESE ARE
MEMBERS FILE ITEM ONE OR NINE
SB THREE SIXTY SIX FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CROCKERY
WITH MATH SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY SIX WITH A MEMBERS BY
SOME MEMBER PERKS OVER THIS
QUICK SILVA ON THE MEMONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
I'M VISITING SB THREE SIXTY SIX
BY SENATOR UMBERG FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. AND
MOMENTS INCORPORATE
DEFINITIONAL CHANGES IN A NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENT FOR THE
VEHICLE DISMANTLING INDUSTRY
START STRIKE TEAM. TO
ADMINISTER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
ADVANCEMENT. THANK YOU MISS
CLARK SILVA AT THAT AND SHE
ACTION. WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED
SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
MEMBERS ARE NOT THE BILL'S NOT
THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE TEM
SIXTY FOUR THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY FOUR. SB THREE THREE
FOUR. INCORPORATE THIS IS ALSO
AMENDMENTS CARBERY WITH MATTERS
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY FOUR
WITH A MEMBERS BIASED MEMORY IS
THIS RACE ON THE MEMONS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AMENDMENTS
TO SP THREE THIRTY FOR THE
DETENTION FACILITY COUNT
ABILITY ACT OUR TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MS REYES WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE
EYES HAVE IT. MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS UP PRINTER BACK
ON FILE. N. FILE ORDER. WE ARE
AT FILE ITEM ONE TEN SB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT SEPARATE. SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SIMILARLY MON AND ACTUALLY TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE DR RABIA
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
THREE SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
LEMOND WHICH REQUIRES HEALTH
PLANS TO COMMUNICATE FOR EVERY
MONTH IN WHICH HEALTH BENEFITS
WERE USED AND UNTIL CONSUMERS
REACH THEIR FULL DEDUCTIBLE OR
MAXIMUM OUT OF POCKET COSTS. SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT ENSURES THAT
PEOPLE HAVE THE MOST CURRENT
INFORMATION ON THERE ARE POOLS
TO ALLOW FOR MORE TRANSPARENCY
FROM HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DECORATE
REALIZADO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLICK OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE- IS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IS THAT A
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TIME BUT I FORTY THREE KNOWS
TWELVE. THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE ELEVEN SB
THREE SIXTY NINE CORKERY SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACCLIMATE TO
FLOOD CONTROL THIS AGUIAR-CURRY
YOU MAY OPEN GOOD MORNING
MISTER SPEAKER THE COUNTIES OF
SACRAMENTO YOLO SOLANO IN MANY
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT RESIDE
ALONG NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATERWAYS. ARTIST SEVERE RISK
OF MAJOR FLOODING IN ORDER TO
PROTECT LIFE AND PROPERTY-
PROPERTY FUTURE FLOOD CONTROL
MASTER MEASURES MUST INCLUDE
COORDINATED KERR COOPERATION BY
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO ENSURE PROPER
PLANNING AND STAKEHOLDER
COLLABORATION SB THREE SIXTY
NINE ONE SURE THAT THE STATE IS
PREPARED FOR A NATURAL DISASTER
BY SALVAGING THE YELLOW BYPASS
CASH SLOOP PARTNERSHIP. AND THE
PARTNERSHIP'S PARTICIPATIONS
MEMORIALIZED IN THIS BILL VIA
VIA AN MO YOU SIGNED BY FIFTEEN
STATE LOCAL AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES WILL CALL FOR THE
PREPARATION OF A MASTER PLAN TO
REFLECT THE INTERESTS OF THOSE
WHO UTILIZE AND BENEFIT THE L.
A BY PASS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING SB THREE SIXTY NINE.
C. NOTIFICATION AVE. CARCLUB
THE ROLE. IS THAT OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL. TELEVOTE. FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
TWELVE THROUGH ONE FIFTEEN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
BONTA FILE ITEM. ONE SIXTEEN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTEEN. SB FOUR FOUR SIX
COVERAGE. SENATE BILL FOR FORTY
SIX BY CENTER GLAZER AND OTHERS
AN APPLICANT'S CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE MR SANTIAGO THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER SB FOUR FOUR SIX
WOULD TO SIMPLY REMOVE THE
BARRIERS FOR WRONGLY CAN FOR
THE WRONGLY CONVICTED WHO AND
WOULD COMPENSATE THE FOR THE
TIME THEY SPEND UNJUSTLY
IMPRISONED THIS BILL PUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE AG'S
OFFICE AND COMPENSATION CLAIMS
RATHER THAN THE REQUIRED PERSON
WHO'S BEEN WRONGLY CONVICTED TO
PROVE THAT THEY ARE INNOCENT-
THIS BILL ZERO ZERO NO VOTES
AND HAS YOUR OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY OFFER MY BOAT.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
IS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- WELL CLOSER
ALL TIRED BUT I FIFTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
AHEAD IN THE FILE. TO FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY SEVEN MS CARILLO.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
SEVEN. SB FORTY FOUR KERKORIAN.
SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. MISS KOREA. YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB FORTY
FOUR WOULD ESTABLISH AN
EXPEDITED SEQUEL REVIEW FOR
SEVEN GREEN LINE TRAINS AND
PROJECT IN LOS ANGELES AND
REQUIRED THAT THE COURTS
RESOLVED RELATED SEQUEL
LAWSUITS WITHIN THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS. THE SOONER
THESE TRANSFORMATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFICIAL
TRANSIT PROJECTS CAN COMPLETE
THE SEQUEL PROCESS AND ARE
BUILT THE FASTER THEY WILL
DISPLAY ITS LATEST LESS
EFFICIENT AND POLLUTION
INTENSIVE REGIONAL TRIPS TAKEN
BY PASSENGERS AND PRIVATE
VEHICLES. IN ORDER TO BE
GRANTED EXPEDITED JUDICIAL
REVIEW THE PROJECT MUST BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE REGION'S
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
STRATEGY AND TRANSPORTATION
PLAN OPERATE AT ZERO EMISSIONS
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
WITHOUT USING OFFSETS END
REDUCE OVERALL VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED IN THE QUARTER WITH
THE PROJECT OPERATE. THE BILL
IS SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO
LAST YEAR'S SB FIVE SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN WHICH PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WAS VETO
BECAUSE THEY'VE WITH CONTINGENT
WITH ANOTHER BILL THAT NOT
REACH THE GOVERNOR'S DESK THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED ROTH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CARRILLO.
C. NOTIFICATION AVE ON THE ITEM.
CARPAL OF THE ROLE. IS THAT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRABLE. WELL CLOSER ALL
TYLER I FIFTY THREE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES AND MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WHERE WERE TO
MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM TWO
TWO NINE SB THIRTY FIVE.
CORPORATION SENATE BILL THIRTY
FIVE BY CENTER- BURKE AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS
MR BERMAN EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
THIRTY FIVE A BILL THAT MAKES
CRITICAL IMPROVEMENTS TO STATE
ELECTIONS LAW PRIOR TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO PRIMARY
ELECTION THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
VOTERS ARE NOT BLOCKED IT
MISLED OR INTIMIDATED WHEN
CASTING THEIR BALLOTS IT ALSO
MAKES CLARIFYING CHANGES ON
CANDIDATE FILINGS IN ORDER TO
HELP IMPLEMENT EXISTING LAW.
SPECIFICALLY SB THIRTY FIVE
WOULD EXPAND THE NO ELECTION
HEARINGS ON SURROUNDING POLLING
SITES TO PROTECT EVERY VOTER IN
LINE REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY'RE STANDING PROHIBIT THE
OBSTRUCTION OF A POLLING PLACE
CLARIFY THAT THE WORD OFFICIAL
IT MAY NOT APPAR ON UNOFFICIAL
BALLOT BOXES IN THIS IS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE IN
IMPLEMENTING CURRENT LAW BY
ALIGNING THE DEADLINE FOR
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATES TO
PROVIDE COPIES OF THE TAX
RETURNS WITH THE CANDIDATE
FILING DEADLINE SB THIRTY FIVE
ALSO GIVES GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REMEDY ANY DEFICIENCIES IN
THEIR TAX RETURN FILINGS. SB
THIRTY FIVE WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT SYSTEM FOR
ELECTIONS MOVING FORWARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
MISS BERMAN. EMAIL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. ON THE ADAM CORPORAL
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF BUT IS THAT OF A.
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
EYES FORTY SIX NO SEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
RETURNING TO FILE ORDER. WE'RE-GOING TO PASS A RETAINER FILE
ITEM. ONE EIGHTEEN. THAT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN.
SB FIVE TEN BURGLARY SENATE
BILL FIVE TEN BY CENTER PAN AN
ACCOLADE IN THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE DECLARE THE YEARS
EITHER OF THE QUEBEC MEDIALLY.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY I THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB FIVE TEN
REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS INSURERS
TO COVER COVER NINETEEN TESTING
AND VACCINATION. WITHOUT COST
SHARING FOR PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
FROM BOTH IN NETWORK AND OUT OF
NETWORK PROVIDERS DURING THE
FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
BECAUSE MY COVERT NINETEEN.
THESE PROTECTIONS REMAIN FOR
SERVICES PROVIDED BY IN NETWORK
PROVIDERS FOLLOWING THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE FEDERAL
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. THIS
BILL ALSO PROHIBITS BALANCE
BILLING BY PROVIDERS FOR COVERT
NINETEEN TESTING IMMUNIZATIONS
EVEN AFTER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY EXPIRES. THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THIS PANDEMIC HAVE
LED TO A FRAMEWORK THAT THIS
BILL PUTS IN PLACE THAT WOULD
ALLOW FEDERALLY APPROVED
TESTING IN IMMUNIZATIONS WITH
NO COST SHARING FOR A FUTURE
PANDEMIC. SB FIVE TEN IS A MUCH
NEEDED BILL BECAUSE OF FEDERAL
AND STATE AGENCIES HAVE SET OUT
EVOLVING AND SOMETIMES
CONFLICTING GUIDANCE WHICH HAS
MADE IT CONFUSING FOR PATIENTS.
AND PROVIDERS TO KNOW WHEN THEY
WILL BE CHARGED. THE SCIENCE IS
CLEAR. TESTING SYMPTOMATIC AND
ASYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS ALONG
WITH THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO COVER NINETEEN IS
CRUCIAL TO STOPPING THE SPREAD.
WE ARE STILL LIVING IN THIS
PANDEMIC WE CANNOT LOSE SIGHT
OF ENSURING EVERYONE HAS ACCESS
TO COPE NINETEEN TESTING AND
VACCINATIONS WITH NO OUT OF
POCKET COSTS. THIS IS WHY SB
FIVE TEN IS NEEDED NOW THERE
NEEDS TO BE A CONSISTENT LAWS
REGARDING HOLDEN NINETEEN
TESTING AND IMMUNIZATIONS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES. FIFTY FOUR. ON THE
URGENCY. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS FOR THEIR
DESIRED ABOUT THIS TAKES. FIFTY
FOUR. MS AGUIAR-CURRY MOVES A
CALL.
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY AND
ONE TWENTY ONE. PASS AND RETAIN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
TWO. S. B. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
CORPORATE. SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY FIVE BY CENTER LEóN AND
OTHERS IMMACULATE IN THE HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE THIS GONZALEZ.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE STREAMLINES THE
BIOMARKER TESTING PROCESS FOR
CANCER PATIENTS THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
FOR BAYERN BIOMARKER TESTING IN
PATIENTS WITH ADVANCED OR
METASTATIC STAGE THREE AND FOUR
CANCER. PRIOR AUTHORIZATION CAN
CAUSE DELAYS FROM A FEW WEEKS A
FEW DAYS TO A FEW WEEKS WHICH
IS A MISSED OPPORTUNITY
RECURRENCE OR PROGRESSION AND
ALLOW PATIENTS TO LEAD A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE. SB FIVE THIRTY
FIVE HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS NO LISTED
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU MS GONZALEZ SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CALL THE
ROLL. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS ONE
TWENTY THREE. THROUGH ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. PASS AND RETAIN
THAT BRINGS US TO FALL OUT OF
ONE TWENTY NINE. SB SIX TWENTY
NINE IN THE CORPORATION. SENATE
BILL SIX TWENTY NINE BY CENTER
ROTH AND OTHER SHENANIGANS
IDENTIFICATION CARDS MR STONE
IN THE OPEN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ONE OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT HURDLES PEOPLE
WHO ARE COMING OUT OF
INCARCERATION HAVE IS THE LACK
OF AN OFFICIAL IDENTIFICATION
THIS HOUSES PASSED THE NUMBER
OF POLICIES OVER THE YEARS TO
FACILITATE GETTING
IDENTIFICATIONS INTO THE HANDS
OF PEOPLE AS THEY COME OUT OF
OUR PRISONS AND JAILS THIS BILL
BY SENATOR RAS RAF SB SIX
TWENTY NINE IS THE NEXT. STEP
THIS IS BEEN NEGOTIATED WITH
CDC ARE INFECTED SPONSORED BY
CDCR. AND THE NUMBER OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE TRYING TO
FACILITATE GETTING THIS KIND OF
WORK DONE THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
BILL AN APPROPRIATE STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR ROB. THANK YOU MR STONE.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASADENA
PROBLEMS. ONE THIRTY ONE THIRTY
ONE. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY TWO SB SIX FIFTY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. HARPER
REED WITH THE BENEFITS SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY WITH THE MINUTES
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
MISTER MURATSUCHI ON THE M. M.
S. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SB SIX
FIFTY WILL BRING GREATER
TRANSPARENCY TO NURSING HOME
RELATED PARTY TRANSACTIONS THIS
IS A CRITICAL TO ENSURE GREATER
STATE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
NURSING HOMES AND THEIR
OPERATIONS PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
WILL PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS. AND
INFORMATION MORE TIME TO
COMPLETE REGULATIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT YOU MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINTER BACK ON
FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE
THIRTY THREE. SB SIX SIXTY.
CORPORATE SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY
BY CENTER NEWMAN AND OTHERS AN
ALKYLATING TO ALEXION'S.
STRELOW YOU MAIL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SB SIX SIXTY HELPS
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTORAL PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MR LOW MR GALLAGHER. YOUR
RESIDENCE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AYE AYE RISE TO
OPPOSE SB SIX SIXTY. YOU KNOW
THERE ARE THINGS WRONG WITH OUR
INITIATIVE PROCESS. THERE ARE
THINGS WE NEED TO FIX ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS.
THIS IS NOT ONE OF THEM. THIS
IS GETTING IN THE WAY OF
GRASSROOTS ACTIVISM OF PEOPLE
GOING OUT EVERYDAY CITIZENS.
PETITIONING GETTING SIGNATURES
TO GET INITIATIVES ON THE
BALLOT. AND YES WHEN YOU DO
WORK. WHEN YOU DO THIS VITAL
WORK YOU SHOULD GET PAID FOR IT-
AND SO. THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH PEOPLE GETTING PAID TO GET
SIGNATURES TO SUPPORT
INITIATIVE THAT PEOPLE EITHER
SIGN IF THEY SUPPORTED OR NOT
IT'S UP TO THE CITIZEN IS NOT
UP TO THE PERSON GATHERING THE
SIGNATURES THE CITIZEN
THEMSELVES WHO DECIDED THIS IS
A WORTHWHILE INITIATIVE. BUT TO
TALK ABOUT THIS IS AS- AS
INTEGRITY WHEN WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE VOTER ID IN THIS STATE. TO
TALK ABOUT THIS ISN'T INTEGRITY
A MEASURE WHEN WE STILL ALLOW
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO WRITE
BIASED TITLES AND SUMMARIES OF
INITIATIVES THEY COMPLETELY
MISS REP MISREPRESENT. WHAT
THOSE INITIATIVES DO. AND WE
HAD SEVERAL OF THOSE. AND TIME
AND TME AGAIN WE BROUGHT THAT
BILL TO ALLOW FOR AN UNBIASED
INDEPENDENT REVIEW OF THAILAND
SUMMARIES OF THE TITLES AND
SUMMARIES ACCURATELY REFLECT.
WHAT IS BEING VOTED ON THIS
THIS BODY BILL TO DOWN BUT
ANYTHING ABOUT GRASSROOTS
ACTIVISM AND I FULLY EXPECT IT
NEXT SESSION WILL SEE CHANGES
TO THE RECALL RULES RIGHT.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE IT WHEN
CITIZENS ACTUALLY EXERCISE
THEIR- RIGHTS THEIR RIGHTS MR
BERMAN STATE LEADERS WHEN I
ASKED MY FRIEND FROM NICOLAS
SPEAK TO THE MERITS OF THIS
BILL AND NOT ANY OTHER CONCERNS
OR CONSPIRACY THEORIES HE HAS.
I'M SORRY MISTER BURMA PLEASE
RESTATE A POINT OF ORDER I ASK
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM NICHOLAS
SPEAK TO THE MERITS AND FACTS
OF THIS BILL. AND NOT ANYTHING
ELSE THAT MIGHT YOU MIGHT BE
WORRIED ABOUT. POINT OF ORDER
IS WELL TAKEN MR GALLAGHER
PLEASE SECOND FINAL COMMENTS TO
THE MERITS OF THE BILL BEFORE
THE HOUSE. WELL FIRST OF ALL
IT'S POINT OF ORDER NOT
OBJECTION WE ARE IN THE
COURTROOM. I HAVE BEEN IN A
COURT ROOM THOUGH ACTUALLY. I
HAVE BEEN IN COURT MISS. WORLD
I'VE ROLLED ON THE POINT OF
ORDER. BUT WE ARE SPEAKING TO
THE MERITS OF VOTER INTEGRITY.
IN OUR SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT. I
REALIZE I'VE TOUCHED A NERVE.
WITH MY COLLEAGUE BECAUSE HE
KNOWS THAT IS VERY TRUE. THAT
WE REJECTED BALLOT INTEGRITY.
MEASURES IN HIS COMMITTEE- AND
WE KNOW THAT IS VERY TRUE THAT
THIS BODY HASN'T STOOD UP. TO
STOP CHANGES TO OUR ELECTION
LAW. BY A GOVERNOR WITHOUT THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT I REALIZE
THAT TOUCHES A NERVE BECAUSE HE
HASN'T HAD THE COURAGE TO STAND
UP TO THOSE THINGS. BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS MISS MISS
BIRKHEAD IS A MINIMUM ORDER I
WOULD ASK THE GENTLEMAN FROM
NICOLAS PLEASE NOT ATTACK A
FELLOW MEMBER ON THE FLOOR. MS
BURKE A HEN. THE POINT OF ORDER
IS WELL TAKEN MR GALLAGHER I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU. AGAIN CAN
FIND YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
MERITS OF THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
BILL BEFORE THE HOUSE. THE
POINT THAT I'M MAKING AND THAT
BOTHERS SOME. IS THAT IT IS A
MISREPRESENTATION TO ATTACK THE
CITIZENS MOVEMENTS THAT ARE
PUTTING INITIATIVES THEY'RE
PUTTING RECALLS ON THE BALLOT
INSTEAD OF ATTACKING THE
PROCESS. AND THE
MISREPRESENTATIONS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED RIGHT HERE IN THIS
BODY THAT HAVE HAPPENED RIGHT
HERE IN OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO PROTECT OUR VOTING SYSTEM
TO PROTECT OUR INITIATIVE AND
THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE HAVE
ACCURATE. INFORMATION THAT
THEY'RE VOTING ON. AND TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
BALLOT BOX. THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE
WORKING ON TO ME THIS ATTACKS
THE CITIZENS. WHO HAVE EVERY
RIGHT. TO PUT ON INITIATIVES TO
CALL FOR RECALLS FOR
REFERENDUMS. ATTACKING THAT
CITIZEN. THE MOST PRO DEMOCRACY
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE IS THE
WRONG THING TO DO AND I URGE A
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL. I SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. OR
DEBATE. THANK YOU FOR THE JOLT
OF ADRENALINE. MR LOW YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
TOOK OVER THERE ALL THE RESULT.
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS OF WHO DESIRED ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF.
HIGHS FORTY TWO NO SIXTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE
TO THIRTY FOUR THROUGH ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. PASS RETAIN THIS
IS FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY NINE.
SB SEVEN EIGHTEEN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CORPORATE
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTEEN WITH A MINUTES
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
THIS DIMENSION ON THE MINUTES
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THESE
MOMENTS RESOLVE CHAPTER IN
CONFLICTS WITH SB TWO FIVE FIVE
IN SB THREE TWENTY SIX TO MAKE
A FEW MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I HAVE A. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOTE VOICE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE IT
MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR. BILLS UP
PRINTED BACK ON FILE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM. ONE FORTY. SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORPORATE WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN WITH A MINUTE'S
BIASED MEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
THIS GONZALEZ ON THE MINUTES
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN BY CENTER
LEYVA THESE ARE CONFORMING
AMENDMENTS REQUESTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE DIRECT
CONTRACTORS RECEIVE AT LEAST
THIRTY DAYS NOTICE PRIOR TO THE
COMMENCEMENT OF ANY ACTION
RESPECT LAST NIGHT VOTE. ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT. MM SORT THE
BILL'S UP PRINTED BACK ON FILE.
WE ARE. PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS ONE FORTY ONE ONE FORTY
TWO. WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM. ONE
FORTY THREE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY FOUR S. B. EIGHT
HUNDRED CORKERY SENATE BILL
EIGHT HUNDRED BY CENTER
ARCHULETA AND OTHERS IMMACULATE
IN A REAL ESTATE MR LOW YOU
MAILED ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SPEAKING COLLEAGUES THIS IS.
COMING BACK TO HELP ENSURE THAT
A WE HAVE THE PROTECTIONS IN
REAL ESTATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. C. NOTIFICATION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ROADSIDE ABOUT.
WELL CLOSE ROLLTIDE OF AYE AYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WHEN A PASSER
CANNOT FILE ITEM. ONE FORTY
FIVE. AND PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY SIX. ONE FORTY
SEVEN AND ONE FORTY EIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM. ONE FORTY NINE PASS
AND RETAIN OF OUT OF ONE FIFTY.
ONE FIFTY ONE. AT ONE FIFTY TWO
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY THREE. SB FOUR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CORPORATE
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
FOUR WITHIN MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS FOR SENATE BILL FOR.
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR GONZALEZ
THESE AMENDMENTS REPRESENT A
NEGOTIATED BROADBAND PACKAGE
BETWEEN THE SENATOR AND I AND
WILL ENSURE BOTH AB FOURTEEN
AND SB FOUR WILL BE IN ACTED
TOGETHER. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS FOR US BEFORE.
FAMOUS AGUIAR-CURRY WITHOUT
OBJECTION AND WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT. YOU MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR
BILLS OUT THE PRINTER BACK ON
FILE. BEVERAGE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE
UP. FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE THIS
IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE SENATE
BILL. FORTY EIGHT. AND THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
FORTY EIGHT BY CENTER LIMóN
AND OTHERS AN OUTLET IN THE
MEDICO MISTER NAZARIAN YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY
EIGHT BY CENTER LIMóN THE BILL
CREATES A- AN INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM TO GIVE MEDICAL
PROVIDERS TRAINING VALIDATED
ASSESSMENT TOOLS AND PAYMENT
INCENTIVES FOR CONDUCTING
COGNITIVE HEALTH ASSESSMENTS.
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THE
STATEWIDE GOAL OF IMPROVED
ALZHEIMER'S DETECTION AND
DIAGNOSIS. LESS THAN HALF OF
THE INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S RIGHT NOW HAVE IT
DIAGNOSED SO WE NEED TO KEEP
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS. IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO NOT ONLY HELP WITH
THEIR LIVES AND THEIR LOVED
ONES LOVED ONES LIVES BUT ALSO.
CONTAIN THE COSTS FOR THE STATE
IN THE FUTURE WITH THAT I
RESPECT LAST FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM THE CLUB OF
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WERE
DESIRABLE. ALL MEMBERS WERE
DESERVE A. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WHO'S READY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
NINE. FILE ITEM. ONE FORTY
NINE. SB. EIGHT FIFTEEN.
CORPORATE SENATE BILL EIGHT
FIFTEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE AND AFTER LEAVING
TO MEET. MYSTERY THIS YOU MAY
OPEN. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
EXTEND SEVERAL SUNSET DOESN'T
PROVISIONS RELATED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE'S LIVESTOCK AND
POULTRY INSPECTION AND
LICENSING PROGRAM SUSPECT
THAT'S WHEN I VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS REAVIS. SANDO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM CIRCLE
FOR THE ROLE. IS THERE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF IT I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE FILE ITEM ONE OF
SIX. THIS IS MR SANTIAGO FILE
ITEM ONE OF SIX. SENATE BILL
THREE FORTY ONE. IN THE
CORPORATE. THESE ARE AMENDMENTS
THIS IS SENATE BILL THREE FORTY
ONE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORPORATION SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY ONE WITH A
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO MR SANTIAGO ON THE
MAMMOTHS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE MEMBERS ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE MEMBERS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS
UP PRINTED BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FALL THE TAKE UP
FILE ITEM. EIGHTY SEVEN. F.
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN. THIS IS
SENATE BILL TWENTY THREE.
CORRECT SENATE BILL TWENTY
THREE BY CENTER RUBIO AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
DISORDERLY CONDUCT THIS PARA
QUE HAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
SB TWENTY THREE WHICH
STRENGTHENS PROTECTIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF REVENGE PORN
EXISTING LAW ONLY ALLOWS
PROSECUTION WITHIN ONE YEAR OF
IMAGES BEING SHARED THIS CAN
SEVERELY LIMIT ACCOUNTABILITY
IF THE VICTIM DOES NOT QUICKLY
DISCOVERED WHAT HAS HAPPENED
WRENCH PORN CAN RUIN CAREERS
AND IS SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH
IMPACTS FOR VICTIMS. THE BILL
MAKES COMMON SENSE CHANGES TO
START THE TATCHELL STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FROM WHEN IMAGES
ARE DISCOVERED BY THE VICTIM
THIS IS A NEEDED STEP TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OFFENDERS
AND JUSTICE FOR VICTIMS OF THIS
DEVASTATING CRIME THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK IS BACK
THERE. C. NOTIFICATION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM COR CALL THE
ROLL. MEMBERS WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ABOUT IT IS THAT
ABOUT. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
EYES FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
CAN MEMBERS
BACK IN FILE ORDER. WE'RE GONNA
PASS TEMPORARILY. ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT. PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
NINE. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
MISS FRIEDMAN HAS AMENDMENTS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
SENATE BILL SIXTY THREE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CORKERY
WITHIN MINUTES SENATE BILL
SIXTY THREE WITH THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN THIS
FRIEDMAN ON M. M. S. THANK YOU
MEMBERS SB SIXTY THREE TAKE
SEVERAL STEPS TO ENGAGE
COMMUNITIES IN FIRE RESILIENCY
EFFORTS AND EXPANDS THE USE OF
FIRE SAFE BUILDING STANDARDS IN
HIGH AND SEVERE FIRE HAZARD
ZONES THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
WERE MODIFIED THE FACTORS THE
DIRECTOR FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION. MUST USED TO
IDENTIFY AREAS OF FIRE SEVERITY
AMARU OF ANY UNECESSARY
GUIDELINES FOR FUEL
MODIFICATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANKS
FRIEDMAN THOUGHT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE FOR. ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT MS
OUR DOCTOR BILLS UP FRONT TO
BACK ON FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY ONE. SENATE BILL
SIXTY FIVE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. CORPORATE WITHIN
MINUTES SENATE BILL SIXTY FIVE
WITH THE MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE MS BURKE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SB SIXTY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA MON ABOUT THE ACT
THESE AMENDMENTS MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES AT THE REQUEST OF THE
MINISTRATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE MINUTES
ARE DOCTOR BILLS OUT THE
PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
RIGHT
WHEN A PASS AND RETAIN. ALUMS
ONE SIXTY TWO THROUGH ONE SIXTY
SIX PASS TEMPORARILY. ON FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY SEVEN. PASS AND
RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. PASS TEMPORARILY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY SEVEN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SEVEN
SENATE BILL ONE TEN. CORPORATE
SENATE BILL ONE TEN BY CENTER
WIENER AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
IN THE MEDICO. MISS IRWIN EMAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
ONE TEN WHICH REQUIRES THAT
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT
INTERVENTIONS BE OFFERED AS AN
OPTIONAL BENEFIT UNDER MEDICALS
ORGANIZED DELIVERY SYSTEM
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS NOT IN VIOLATION
OF STATE ANTI KICKBACK LAWS FOR
HEALTH TREATMENTS CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS A SCIENTIFICALLY
PROVEN FORM OF BEHAVIORAL
INTERVENTION THAT USES POSITIVE
INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO ABSTAIN FROM DRUG USE AND
REMAIN IN DRUG TREATMENT
PROGRAMS. VETERANS AFFAIRS
HOSPITALS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY CURRENTLY USE
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT
SUCCESSFULLY ACROSS CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY DURING COVERT
NINETEEN SUBSTANCE USE AND
HOSPITALIZATION DUE TO DRUG USE
AND OVERDOSES ARE ALL
SKYROCKETING METHAMPHETAMINES
ARE RAVAGING OUR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THERE IS CURRENTLY NO
MEDICAL INTERVENTION FOR METH
ADDICTION SUCH AS METHADONE FOR
OPIOIDS WE MUST TURN TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INTERVENTIONS
TO SAVE LIVES AND HELP PEOPLE
OBTAIN FROM USING. SB ONE TEN
ENSURES THAT CALIFORNIA IS
EMPLOYING EVERY TOOL POSSIBLE
TO IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH TO
WORK TO END ADDICTION AND
ULTIMATELY TO SAVE LIVES THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES AND IS
SPONSORED BY EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND LEADING
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT GROUPS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
MR ONE SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ADAM. CARCLUB THE ROLE-
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. WELL. CLOSER ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. BACK IN
FILE ORDER RE ON A PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
EIGHT PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
SEVENTY. AND ONE SEVENTY ONE
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY TWO. SENATE BILL TWO
FORTY FOUR IN THE CORPORATION
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
MS GARCIA YOUR MAIL BUT THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SB
TWO FORTY FOUR REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION IN CONSULTATION WITH
RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES LIKE
THE CALIFORNIA C. H. P. D. T.
S. C. AND THE WASTE INDUSTRY.
TO DEVELOP PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PROPER MANAGEMENT OF DISPOSAL
OF LITHIUM ION BATTERIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS GARCIA
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE OUT OF. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF. THEY'RE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTED SAID
ABOUT. HE'S READY FOR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE IN
TELLING THE I. SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT. SENATE BILL
THREE OH THREE SEPARATE. SENATE
BILL THREE OH THREE BY SOON
REPORTERS AND OTHERS IMMACULATE
IN THE TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. MISTER
BIGELOW YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. SB
THREE OH THREE WOULD EXTEND BY
TWO YEARS THE TIME ALLOWED FOR
THOSE WHOSE PROPERTY WAS
DAMAGED OR DESTROYED BY A
GOVERNOR PROCLAIM DISASTER TO
TRANSFER THEIR PROPERTY TAX
BASE YEAR VALUE TO REPLACEMENT
PROPERTY LOCATED WITHIN THE
SAME COUNTY. THIS BILL WOULD
EXTEND THE FIVE YEAR TIME
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHOSE LAST DAY
TO TRANSFER THE BASE YEAR VALUE
OF THEIR PROPERTY WAS ON OR
AFTER MARCH FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY. BUT ON OR BEFORE THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
TERMINATION OR MARCH FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHICHEVER
DATE IS SOONER THE BILL WOULD
ALSO EXTEND THE FIVE YEAR TIME
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHSE PROPERTY
WAS SUBSTANTIALLY DAMAGED OR
DESTROYED ON OR AFTER MARCH
FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY BUT ON OUR
BEEF. ON OR BEFORE THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TERMINATION
WHICH EVER DATE SEEMS TO BE
SOONER. MISTER SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU REST REGULAR SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CARCLUB THE ROLE MEMBERS.
IS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUT OF. WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. BACK IN REGULAR FILE
ORDER IS GONZALEZ. THIS IS.
FILE ITEM. ONE SEVENTY THREE
WE'RE AT FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
THREE SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY TWO
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
COURT AGREED WITH THE MEN
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LORENA GONZALEZ THIS GONZALEZ
ON A MAMMOTH THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SENATOR
HERTZBERG'S. BAIL REFORM BILL
THESE MOMENTS MAKE MINOR
CLARIFICATION AS IT RELATES TO
JUDICIAL DISCRETION OUTLINED IN
THE BILL THESE ARE JUST THE
MOMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY
THE I. SEVEN. YOU MEMBERS ARE
NOT THE BILLS OUT THE PRINTER
BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE FALL
THE TAKE UP MR MCCURDY'S ITEMS.
WE ARE GOING BACK IN THE FILE
THE FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN.
FILE ITEM. NINETY SEVEN. SENATE
BILL TWO TWO SIX OPERATE.
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR PAN AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE MEDICO MISTER
MCCARTY EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL
BY MY SENATOR SENATOR PAN
HELPING US HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY BETTER COORDINATE OUR
MEDIC CAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAMS
ASK YOUR EITHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS RECORD SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEVERAL
OF THE ROLE. THE RESULT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
M.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT SB.
FIFTY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COOPERATE WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL FIFTY
WITH THE MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY MISTER MCCARTY
ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS A BILL
BY SEN EARLY MON RELATING TO
REFORMING OUR CHILD CARE AND
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS.
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS IN NATURE
ASK THE ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
WITHOUT OBJECTION YES MISS
WALDRON WE OPPOSE THIS
AMENDMENTS AND ASK FOR ALL CALL
MISS WALDRON IS WITHHOLDING WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
BETTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THESE ARE THE AMENDMENTS TO SP.
FIFTY- ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
AND TELL YOU THAT I FIFTY KNOWS
FIFTEEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED. BILLS OUT TO PRINCE
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY THREE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY THREE
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY SIX
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORPORATE WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY SIX
WITH A MEMBERS BY SOME REMEMBER
BURKE. IS BURKE ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SB SEVEN NINETY
SIX AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF
THE MEASURE THESE AMENDMENTS
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT LANGUAGE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU MS BURKE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE I. SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT THE PRINTER
BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS WE ARE
GETTING READY TO TAKE. A LUNCH
BREAK WE ARE GOING TO ENTERTAIN
VOTE CHANGES AT THIS TIME
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE A VOTE
CHANGE. BEFORE WE BREAK. MS
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA VOTE
CHANGE ON SB FORTY FOUR ITEM
ONE FIFTY SEVEN FROM I TO NOT
VOTING. VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA SENATE
BILL FORTY FOUR I TO NOT VOTING.
MISTER MATHIS YES VOTE CHANGE
ON FILE ITEM ONE FIVE EIGHT S.
B. FIFTY LA MON NO I. BOTH
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
SENATE BILL FIFTY NO T<c.cyan>. M.</c>
S. DAVIES THANK IS A MEMBER
DAVIES VOTE CHANGE ON SB THIRTY
FIVE FROM I TO KNOW. BURKE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES
SENATE BILL THIRTY FIVE I TO
KNOW. MICHELLE LEVINE. A
SUMMARY LEVINE SB FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR I TO KNOW. BOTH CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE SENATE
BILL FOUR EIGHTY FOUR I TO KNOW.
MEMBERS. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. TO RESCIND THE ACTION
WHEREBY ON SEPTEMBER FIRST
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY DRAWS
IT WAS READ A THIRD TIME AND
PASSED TO THE SENATE. I ASK
THAT THE BILL BE ORDERED BACK
TO THE THIRD READING FILE.
MEMBERS UPON RETURNING FROM THE
LUNCH BREAK WHICH I WILL
ANNOUNCE MOMENTARILY PLEASE BE
PREPARED TO TAKE UP YOUR ITEMS
ON CONCURRENCE. IN THE EVENT
THAT WE SUSPEND THE RULES TO
TAKE UP ADDITIONAL CONCURRENCE
ITEMS. IT COULD HAPPEN. PLEASE
BE PREPARED TO TAKE OF YOUR
ITEMS ON CONCURRENCE.
ADDITIONALLY THE COMMITTEE ON
JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOMENT AND
THE ECONOMY WILL BE MEETING
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER WE BREAK
FOR LUNCH IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN. THEREFORE WE WILL NOW BE
TAKING A LUNCH BREAK. WE WILL
BE RETURNING TO THE FLOOR
PROMPTLY AT ONE PM AND WILL BE
TAKING OF ITEMS AT THAT TIME.
WE ARE IN RECESS. ONE PM
MEMBERS ONE PM RETURN TO THIS
GREEN CARPET.
MEMBERS WE ARE
RESUMING SESSION. MATTHEW
PLEASE RETURN TO THE CHAMBER SO
WE CAN COMMENCE THE AFTERNOONS
BUSINESS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE
RESUMED THE DAY'S BUSINESS THEN
I WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE. YOU
JOINING ME ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL
THE MEMBERS THAT HAVE JOINED US
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR SO WE CAN
RE COMMENCE BUSINESS. YES
MISTER COOPER THANK YOU. BUT MR
COOPER MISTER STATO WAS THE
FIRST MEMBER BACK TO THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TURN TO
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM ONE AB
THREE FORTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE IF YOU GET
CAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
THREE FORTY TWO WHICH IS BACK
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR FOR
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE TECHNICAL AND ADD CO
AUTHORS THIS BILL HAVE RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ONCE AGAIN
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE
VOTE AB. THREE FORTY TWO THANK
YOU MISTER GIPSON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE.
WORK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING ABOUT
ICE FORTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY
SEVEN TO WAIVE THE ONE DAY
WAIT. ON ITEM SEVEN THROUGH
FIFTY ONE INCLUSIVE TO ALLOW
AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THEIR
CONCURRENCE ITEMS TODAY. MISTER
FOREIGN BASED WITHHOLDING HILLS
CONSENT AS A ROLL CALL VOTE HEY
MISS REST MOVES AND- MISS
GONZALEZ SECONDS. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN VERSION.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. MISBRANDED ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MR FLOOR IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
MOTION ALL MEMBERS GO TO
DESERVE A. HOME MEMBERS THIRTY
THIRD VOBIS RACES ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MR FLOOR IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW IT ABOUT FIVE
FORTY THREE KNOWS WELL THE
pRULES ARE SUSPENDED. ZACKS.
LIVING TO WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM TO MOVING THE FILE
ITEM THREE AB THREE FORTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
THREE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
OTHERS ENACTED IN LAND USE.
ESCRICK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB THREE FORTY FIVE IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE IS THE BILL ALLOWS
FOR THE SEPARATE SALE OF
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
INCLUDE ADDING A CO AUTHOR IN
CORRECTING A GRAMMATICAL ERROR
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. CALL
MEMBERS MOVED VERY VOCAL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY TO THEIR- THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THAT I FIFTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS FOUR
THROUGH SIX MOVING TO. FIVE
WILL PASS ARAMBULA ITEM SEVEN
MOVING TO. NOT FILE ITEM EIGHT
BECAUSE THE AUTHOR IS NOT ON
THE FLOOR. YOUR FILE ITEM NINE
MEMBERS I. ATHEY PLEASE RETURN
TO YOUR DESK IF YOU WOULD LIKE
YOUR CONCURRENCE ITEMS HEARD.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING THERE
AND READY SO WE CAN MOVE
THROUGH THE FILE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS NINE
AND TEN MOVING TO A FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB TWO NINETY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL TO
NINETY TWO BY SOME MEMBERS ON
THE BACK LIVING THE
CORRECTIONS. THIS IS HOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWO
NINETY TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
AND HAVING WORKED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE CREDITS
PORTION REMOVING THAT FROM THE
BILL AND JUST ENSURING THAT
INMATES GET THE BENEFIT OF THE
PROGRAMMING. THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN ENTITLED TO AND I ASK FOR
IT I VOTE ON CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENT. THANK YOU MR
ST HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. YEAH YEAH.
YEAH RIGHT. ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD BUT THIS REQUIRES
FORTY ONE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRTY
VOTE. WE DID HE CLOSER TO
FORTY. KIRKO OVER THERE ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE IT
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE. HOWEVER IS
MOVING THE WRITTEN. PLEASE RE
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE I TELLING
DON'T ICE FORTY ONE NEWS TWELVE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. WE'LL MOVE BACK UP IN FILE
ORDER TO FILE ITEM FORTY THREE
SIXTY NINE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY NINE
BY FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KAMLAGER AND OTHERS AND I LIVE
IN AMERICA. AFTER MEMBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY NINE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR COM
LONGER. AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS. TO
REIMBURSE AND ENROLL PROVIDER
INSTEAD OF AUTHORIZING A
PROVIDER TO BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON AB THREE SIXTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR
OVERSEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. CALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. CLAIRE WHOA- CLUES RURAL
AND HOW THE MOVE I SCRIPTED YOU
KNOW ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORD IN. MOVING. PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM TWELVE
ONLY TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
FOR TWELVE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE FOR TWELVE MONTHS
MEMORY AS AND OTHERS MACKLIN IN
THE STATE GOVERNMENT THIS RACE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT YOU EIGHTY FOUR TWELVE
WHICH IS THAT WASHES THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON HUMAN
RIGHTS THE BILL HAS NOT
CONSENTED INCOME ON CONCURRENCE
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN SENATE
WERE TECHNICAL AND REMOVED
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU MISS
REST SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. WHERE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALITA I FIFTY TWO
NEW ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVIE TO FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
FOUR THE KERKORIAN SOME PEOPLE
FOR TWENTY FOUR MONTHS MEMBERS
STONE AND OTHER SNACK WITHIN
THE STUDENT LOANS IT'S JUST ON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS
THE BILL TO PROTECT. STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS WHO TOOK SOME
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THE BANKING INDUSTRY PUT IN AT
THE MINIMUM STANDARD. SO I ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTER CONCURRENCE
AND SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MR STERN. THING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE THIRD WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. NONMEMBERS
THIRTY DESERVE A- CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY THAT
ICE FORTY THREE KNOWS ELEVEN
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
FOUR FORTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME PEOPLE FOR FORTY TWO
BUCKS MEMBER MAYES ENACTED IN
THE SURFACE MINING ESTIMATE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THE MEDICITY
CARE OF AB FOUR FOUR TWO'S BACK
ON CONCURRENCE RESPONSE THE
REQUEST AND I WILL. THANK YOU
MISTER MAYES SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WILL OPEN THERE ARE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED EITHER OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
GO. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO
NEW ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
COMPARED AND WE TO FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB FORTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME OF THE
FORTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AND ACKLIN CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS- WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB FOR AVIATORS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE MADE. CLARIFICATIONS TO
MINIMIZE DAHLE REGISTRATION AND
SOLICITATION CONSENT PROCEDURES
OF THIS BILL CREATES A
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK FOR ONLINE
CHARITABLE GIVING AND A
SPONSORED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND SUPPORTED BY AND
CAL NONPROFITS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
MISTER ONE THING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED THIRD VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
GO TO DESERVE IT. HOME NUMBER
THIRTY THIRTY A. WHERE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLLING TELEVOTE ICE
FORTY SEVEN NEWS THIRTEEN
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED WOULD
VIOLATE IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN THE COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
VICE ON THE RECORD AND I PLAYED
IN THE COMMUNICATIONS SECTOR
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED HIM I
GUESS. IF YOU SPEAKER AB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN IS BAD FOR
CONFLICT CONCURRENT CENTER
MANAGE REMOVE LANGUAGE.
REGARDING DEEMED APPROVED AND
CLARIFY SAFETY STANDARDSIN THE
PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR CONCURRENCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR KIRK SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER WELL OPEN THE-
MEMBERS VOTED VERY TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY NINE NEWS
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE. FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR SB FIVE OH
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE OH THREE BY
CENTER BAKER AND ACTUALLY THE
VOTING BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
FIVE OH THREE A BILL TO IMPROVE
THE SIGNATURE REVIEW PROCESS
FOR VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS. WITH
TENS OF MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS ALREADY VOTING BY MAIL
IT IS IMPERATIVE WE HAVE
UNIFORM STATEWIDE SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION RULES AND
GUIDELINES. MOREOVER CHALLENGED
SIGNATURES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT THE MOST UNDERSERVED
CALIFORNIANS THOSE WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
DISABILITIES FIRST TIME AN
AGING VOTERS AND VOTERS OF
COLOR. THIS BILL REFINED THE
PROCESS FOR VOTERS TO CORRECT
MISSING OR MISMATCHED
SIGNATURES ON THE VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS REQUIRES CONSISTENT
BALLOT REJECTION REPORTING
ACROSS THE STATE. THE AUTHORS
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE SECTOR
STATE AND COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS TO CREATE A WORKABLE
PROCESS. AND ULTIMATELY SB FIVE
OH THREE GIVES CONFIDENCE TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THAT VALID
VOTES ARE IN FACT COUNTED AND I
KNOW THAT A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES. ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE CARE A LOT ABOUT
ELECTION INTEGRITY. AND I WANT
TO ASSURE ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT DO
ANYTHING. THAT MIGHT INCITE A
VIOLENT INSURRECTION OF OUR U.
S. CAPITAL THIS BILL DOES NOT
DO ANYTHING TO HIRE. TOTALLY
UNQUALIFIED COMPANIES TO
CONDUCT AUDITS OF ELECTIONS.
AND THIS BILL IS NOT DO
ANYTHING TO OVERTURN THE
PROPERLY COUNTED VOTES- OF ANY
STATES OR ANY ELECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MR BERMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL PEN THE ROLL. CALL
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF A-
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING ABOUT ICE FIFTY NEWS
THIRTEEN MEMBERSHIP PASSES.
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RESCIND THE ACTION WERE BY
EARLIER TODAY ITEM ONE FORTY
FOUR SB EIGHT HUNDRED ARCHER
THAT THAT WAS READ THE THIRD
TIME AND PASSED TO THE SENATE
PLEASE ORDER THE BILL BACK TO
THIRD READING THAT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RESCIND THE ACTION AND EXPUNGE
THE RECORD WERE BY FLOOR
AMENDMENTS WERE ADOPTED TODAY.
ON ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT SB
FIFTY LIMóN. I ASKED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY BE ALLOWED TO
PRESENT THE FLOOR AMENDMENTS
AGAIN. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RESCIND
THE ACTION WERE BY ON JULY
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE SB
THREE NINETY TWO ARCHULETA. WAS
READ A THIRD TIME AND PASSED TO
THE SENATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR. SB
SIX EIGHT FOUR WEST SO TO THE
INACTIVE FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. YEAH
MEMBERS WE WILL TAKE UP THOSE
AMENDMENTS ONCE AGAIN ON ITEM
ONE FIFTY EIGHT SB FIFTY MR
MCCARTY YOU WOULD PLEASE
INDULGE THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
CERTAINLY MOMENT HOUSE THAT WE
PROCESS MAYES MCCARTY WENT
SECOND THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FIFTY WITH THE
MEMBERS BY SOME MCCARTY
ACTIVISTS REGARDING THANK YOU
ON BEHALF OF CENTER LIMóN
ASKED WE PROCESS THESE
AMENDMENTS AT ONCE AND
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS RELATED
TO STREAMLINING STATE PRE K.
AND CHILD CARE PROGRAMS THANK
YOU. WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE
OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES HAVE IT
THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. OUT TO
PRINT IN BACK ON FILE.
WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NINETY FOUR SB TWO ZERO EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL TWO OH EIGHT BY CENTER
VALLEY AND OTHERS AND I PUT IN
A RESOURCE CONSERVATION. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS SB TWO ZERO EIGHT BY
SENATOR DALLY EXPANDS THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY MODIFIES THE
TERRITORY WITHIN THIS AND THAT
SIERR NEVADA CONSERVANCY MORE
FULLY PROTECT THE SIERRA NEVADA
WATERSHED AND INCREASED THE
PACE AND SCALE OF FORCE
PROJECTS. ARE EAGERLY AWAIT AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER BECAUSE WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE TWO THIRDS VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY ABOUT
I. SIXTY ONE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE OF SIX SB.
THREE FORTY ONE. THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL THREE FORTY
ONE BY SENATE MCGUIRE AND
OTHERS INCLUDING THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS. AFTER
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON A. B. I'M SORRY SB THAT
MR SANTIAGO THIS IS ON
AMENDMENTS. THERE ARE AYE STERN
AYE VOTE ON AMENDMENTS. WE
ALREADY MANY THE BILL NOW WE
NEED TO WAIT I APOLOGIZE.
WELCOME BACK TO YOU AT A LATER
DATE. TRANSACTION.
MEMBERS WILL
NOW TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
SEVEN SB EIGHT OH FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL
INFORMACION REPLACE YOUR AND
OTHER'S MACKLIN THE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION I MEAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SB EIGHT
OH FOUR WOULD CREATE A NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CENTER TO TRAIN
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IN FORESTRY AND
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ACCORDING
TO CAL FIRE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ALONE AN ESTIMATED FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION ACRES BURNED DUE
TO WILD FIRES THESE FIRES
DAMAGE OVER TEN THOUSAND
STRUCTURES IN COST THIRTY
THREE. FATALITIES THIS YEAR HAS
A SIMILAR STORY THIS COMES
AFTER THE SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN WILDFIRE SEASONS WHICH
WERE THE DEADLIEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE IN STATE HISTORY
WITH COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
THIS CENTER WOULD ACCOMPLISH
THE GOAL OF EXPANDING THE
WORKFORCE AND IMPLEMENTING A
VEGETATION AND FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT PLAN. THIS PROGRAM
NOT ONLY WORK TOWARDS REDUCING
THE TOLL OF WILDFIRES BUT ALSO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM RATES AND
CREATE A PATHWAY TO GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT FOR THOSE WHO'VE
COMPLETED CONFINEMENT IN LOCAL
JAILS OR STATE INSTITUTIONS
THIS BILL IS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MR LEVINE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ABOUT OF THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALENT I SIXTY TWO NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
FOUR S. B. TWENTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATE SKINNER
AND OTHERS MACKLIN AIR
POLLUTION. HISTORY THAT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THE- LATEST REPORT FROM
THE U. N.'S INTERGOVERNMENTAL
PANEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE
EMPHASIZE THAT WE ONLY HAVE A
BRIEF WINDOW LEFT. TO ADDRESS
OUR CLIMATE CRISIS. NATURE
BASED. SOME SOLUTIONS LIKE-
INSURING THAT WE CULTIVATE
HEALTHY WETLANDS AND FORESTS AS
WELL AS ENSURING THAT WE
PROMOTE HEALTHY SOILS ARE
AGRICULTURAL LANDS ARE SOME OF
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE AND
PROVEN MECHANISMS DISKS AQUESTA
CARBON. THIS LEGISLATION SEEKS
TO PROMOTE THESE NATURE BASED
CARBON SEQUESTRATION SOLUTIONS.
BY DIRECTING STATE AGENCIES TO
SET GOALS FOR- FOR NATURAL
CARBON REMOVAL AND ESTABLISHING
A VOLUNTARY REGISTRY OF
CALIFORNIA'S- OF A CALIFORNIA
BASED CARBON SEQUESTRATION
PROJECTS IN THESE PROJECTS
WHICH- COULD ATTRACT PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INVESTMENT TO HELP
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE. THIS
MEASURE SUPPORTED BY MY MALE
GROUPS THE BUILDING TRADES AND
MANY OTHERS RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MYSTERY THIS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. HOWEVER THIRTY TO THIRTY
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THAT I SIXTY ONE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. DO
YOU KNOW IF.
WE ARE GOING TO
TURN TO YOU MISTER CHANG ON
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE. SB
TWO SIXTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL 264% OF MEN
AND OTHERS AN ACTIVE IN THE
FARMS THIRTEEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER PROUD TO PRESENT SB TWO
SIXTY FOUR BEHALF OF SENATOR
MEN. WILL TO PROHIBIT THE SALE
OF FIREARMS AMMUNITION AND
FIREARM PRECURSOR PARTS ON
STATE. PROPERTY OR FACILITATING
GUNS JONES AT THE THIRTY SECOND
DISTRICT AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWN AS THE
ORANGE COUNTY FAIR AND EVENT
CENTER. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN I CO
AUTHORED S. B. TWO TWO ONE
WHICH HAD A SIMILAR PROVISION
FOR OUR CAL PALACE. ALTHOUGH
THE LEGISLATION WAS VETOED
WE'RE VERY HAPPY THAT THE COW
PALACE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
DECIDE TO STOP HOSTING GUN
SHOWS THAT OUR EFFORTS WERE
RECOGNIZED. SB TWO SIX FORCE
BEEN NARROWED TO DIGEST ORANGE
COUNTY SPECIFICALLY. AND IT'S
WIDELY BELIEVED THAT GUN SHOWS
IN PARTICULAR ARE MAJOR CONDUIT
FOR THE SALE. OF GHOST GUNS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON S. B. TWO SIX
FOUR. THANK YOU MR TANG. DR
CHOI YOU ARE A ON THE MAT.
THANK YOU MADAM AND THE MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE. IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO A SENATE BILLS TO
A SIXTY FOUR WHICH BANS OF GUNS
TOOLS ARE AND THE- THOUGH SALES
OF A FIRE ARM SO AND THE
AMMUNITION IN ORANGE COUNTY
FAIRGROUND THE PROPERTY. THIS
BILL IS ALL ON NO IN
APPROPRIATE. RESTRICTIONS ON
NOT COUNTY PROPERTY WHICH WILL
NOT ONLY FOR THE LOCAL TAX
REVENUES WHILE DOING NOTHING TO
ANY PREVIOUS OFF ON THE SAFETY.
MANY COUNTY FAIR BOARD STILL
BARELY SURVIVED THE FINANCIAL.
WE SHOULD NOT THE ARBITRAL THE
LIMIT THE TYPES OF EVENTS THAT
CAN OCCUR OR NO STATE
FAIRGROUNDS. COUNTY FAIR SO
RECEIVE A MINIMUM SUPPORT THE
ANNUALLY FROM THE STATE BUDGET
FARES ARE EXPECTED TO GENERATE
THEIR OWN REVENUE SO FROM TRADE
SHOWS. LIVESTOCK OF OCEANS.
CONCERTS ARE AS CERTAIN AND SO.
ADDITIONAL A GUN ARE IF
ANYTHING MORE SECURE WORKPLACES
FOR CONDUCTING FIREARM
TRANSACTIONS OF THAN A BRICK
AND MORTAR RETAIL LOCATIONS
ACTIVITIES SO THERE ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE OF SERVICE TO BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE JUSTICE OR
AGENTS OF. THEM AT THE
INDIVIDUAL FIRE ARMS SO
RETAILERS RETAIL STORE
LOCATIONS. STILL IT IS TO HAVE
ALSO SHOWN THAT THE FILE YOUR
ARM OF A QUIET AT THE GUN SHOWS
OFF ON NOT ANY MORE LIKELY TO
BE USED IN CRIME. IT MAKES NO
SENSE TO ABANDON A SPECIFIC
PARTS OF THE EVENTS THAT-
ORANGE COUNTY FIRE FILLED WRONG
SO CAN HOST IS SPECIAL LEVINE
WE ARE ALL STRUGGLING TO
RECOVER FROM. THIS OF ALL THE
INDEPENDENT. WHAT DO THE NEXT
DAY AND THE- HANDBAG SALES. OR
ANIMAL DISPLAYS. WHY ORANGE
COUNTY ONLY. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE A NO VOTE THE HORN S. B.
TWO SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU DOCTOR CHOICE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER CAN YOU MAKE
THOSE. BIGGER ON MY COLLEAGUES
FROM ORANGE COUNTY BUT BUT THE
POINT THE BILL ORIGINALLY-
PERTAINING TO ALL STATE- COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS BUT WAS NARROWED
COMING OUT OF APPROPRIATIONS
FOR JUST THIS PARTICULAR ORANGE
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS IT LEADS- IF
FOLLOWS THE LEAD OF- THE DEL
MAR STATE FAIRGROUNDS IS
ILLEGAL WHERE ARE NOW FORMER
COLLEAGUE THERE GLORIA CARRY
THAT BILL THAT WAS CHAPTER IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AGAIN WE ARE
STRONG PRESIDENT WE SEE THAT
THESE VERY BROWN SHOULD REALLY
BE THERE TO EXPAND AND
DEMONSTRATE THE GREAT
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE YOU REALLY
SHOULD BE A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
SHOULD BE BUYING AND SELLING
FIREARMS WITHOUT RESPECT FOR US
FOR A VOTE ON SB. TWO SIXTY
FOUR. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO IT. FROM
VOTERS ARE A CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE SAW
THREE NO SEVENTY THAT MEASURE.
WILL MOVE UP IN FILE OR FOR ONE
SIX ITEMS ONCE TWO SB NINE FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. PICTURE
WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SIXTY NINE WITH LIMITS BY SOME
MEMBER WOULD. SURE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- THE
MCMENAMINS ARE MINOR TECHNICAL
THE AUTHORS WORK WITH THE
ASSEMBLY POLICY COMMITTEES AND
ADMINISTRATION EVERYWHERE ONE
SECTION GIVEN THE POTENTIAL
TRANSFER OF AGENCY ASSETS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND FURTHER
CLARIFY THE STATE WILL NOT BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY POTENTIAL
LIABILITIES AND MAKE ONE COULD
CHANGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SENIOR FOR THE DEBATE ON THE
MATTER WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
WELL OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT IN BACK ON
FILE. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE SEVENTY SIX THROUGH
ONE EIGHTY MOVED TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY ONE SB THREE
FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FOURTEEN BY
SIR WE ARE AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE IN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
DECLARE THE OF SIERRA PACIFIC
MEDIA. MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR WIENER 2% SB THREE
FOURTEEN WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIA'S NEIGHBORHOOD
RESTAURANTS AND BARS. TO ENSURE
THEY'RE ABLE TO RECOVER
ECONOMICALLY FROM THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. EARLIER THIS
YEAR THIS CHAMBER UNANIMOUSLY
PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY ONE
WHICH TOGETHER WITH SB THREE
FOURTEEN PROVIDES REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITY INCREASE THE
NECESSARY LIFELINE FOR
RESTAURANTS AND BARS. THESE
CHANGES WILL HELP RESTAURANTS
AND BARS ADAPT AND MOVE FORWARD
FROM THE CHALLENGES THEY FACE
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND ENSURE
THAT OUR FUTURE REGULATIONS ARE
MORE USER FRIENDLY FOR THESE
BUSINESSES. THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO. ALL
MEMBERS. THIRTY TO THIRTY. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NEW
ZERO THE URGENCY I SIXTIES YOU
KNOW ZERO ON THE MEASURE THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO SB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY
EIGHT BY CENTER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS NINE MILLION PRIVATE
LOANS. SENATE BILL. THREE
THIRTY EIGHT WITH A WOMEN'S BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO. HERE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED PURPOSES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR GONZALEZ TO
PRESENT AMENDMENTS FOR SENATE
BILL THREE THREE EIGHT THE BILL
HELPS PROTECT ESSENTIAL TRUCK
DRIVERS THE CALIFORNIA PORTS.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE MINOR
ANGLER FIND IN NATURE THE
AMENDMENTS ENSURE THE TRUCKING
COMPANIES WHICH END UP IN THE
BAD ACTOR LISTEN THE DIVISION
OF LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT
WEBSITE WILL NOT BE PRECLUDED
FROM BEING ADDED TO ANY OTHER
LIST HOUSE. ON THE OTHER ON THE
OTHER STATE AND ENTITIES
WEBSITE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS
CARILLO SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE TOOK A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE. OLIGOCENE
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
OR DIE. OUT TO BRING HIM BACK
ON FILE. WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTY. THREE
THROUGH ONE. EIGHTY SEVEN
MOVING THE FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT SB FOUR SIXTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTEEN BY CENTER HUESO AND
OTHERS AN ECHOING THE
CORRECTIONS. MISTER BRIAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
FOUR SIXTEEN INCARCERATED
STUDENTS BILL OF RIGHTS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALLOWED FOR PERSONS
INCARCERATED RECEIVE THE PELL
GRANT. WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
SOMETHING THAT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. WE SEEM TO FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES STILL GI BILLS
PROMISING FALSE OPPORTUNITY AND
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITH THIS
BILL WOULD DO IS PROHIBIT FOR
PROFIT UNIVERSITIES. FROM
STEALING PELL GRANTS AND THOSE
ONE CARS RATED IT REQUIRES THE
CDC ARE ONLY WORK WITH
ACCREDITED NONPROFIT. HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS. THIS
MARBLE IT'S A THOUGHTFUL BILL
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
RESTAURANTEUR QUESTIONABLE.
THANK YOU MISTER BRIAN SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO DESERT ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THAT I FIFTY SEVEN NEWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WILL
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
ONE EIGHTY NINE THROUGH ONE
NINETY ONE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY TWO SB FOUR SIXTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ TO THE
BILL 465% EGGMAN AND OTHERS NOT
GOING TO MENTAL HEALTH. AFTER
EMILY WERE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL FOR SIXTY FIVE BY DOCTOR
EGGMAN. FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE PROGRAMS
INTENDED TO REACH THOSE WITH
THE GREATEST NEEDS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. SB FOUR SIXTY FIVE
WAS CRAFTED WITH SOME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE COMMISSION.
TO REVIEW HELPFUL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE SERVING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND HOW THEY MIGHT
BE IMPROVED. THIS BILL PASSED
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DR
MLSE UNION HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
DESERVE IT. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBER WE
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK UP
IN FILE ORDERS TO A FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY SIX. SB EIGHT OH
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL IT'LL THREE BY
CENTER OFTEN AFTER THE
PROFESSIONS OF LOCATIONS MR LOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS SB EIGHT
ZERO THREE IS ONE OF OUR MANY
SUNSET BILLS AND THE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS FOR
RENEWAL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR LOS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS BOTH.
HOME MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO
VOTE. NUMBER THIRTY TWO THIRDS
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELEVOTE ICE TWO ONE TWO
ZERO EMISSION PASSES WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM OF. ONE
SIXTY NINE. SB TWO TWENTY FOR
THE CORPORATE. SENATE BILL TWO
TWENTY FOUR BY SIR PORTANTINO
ANOTHER SNACK OF THE PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION HELLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AGAIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CLLEAGUES AND MADAM
SPEAKER S. B. TWO TWENTY FOUR
IS AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT
ADDRESSES A VERY CRITICAL ISSUE
WITH RESPECT TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN A SPEEDY
AND EXPEDITIOUS VOTE AND
SUPPORT. TO SEND IT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK IS IMPORTANT
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MR LOW SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. IN THIS VOTE WHERE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS VOTED
AMERICA. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
A. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE EYES FORTY FOUR NEWS
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES. OKAY.
WE ARE MOVING BACK IN FILE
ORDER WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM. ONE NINETY THREE.
WE WILL BE TAKING OUT FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY THREE. SB FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR WIENER AND
OTHERS MACKLIN HOUSING. MR
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES N THE LAST FEW
YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS ADOPTED
SEVERAL LOST HELP ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY DATA COLLECTION
FOR THESE LAWS ARE RANDOM AND
QUITE LIMITED MAKING IT
DIFFICULT TO QUANTIFY EXACTLY
HOW EFFECTIVE THEY ARE.
COLLECTING THE STATE IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. AND IT'S BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN SIMPLY BUILDS OFF
THE EXISTING ANNUAL PRODUCTION
REPORT THAT CITIES ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE STATE.
WITH MORE COMPREHENSIVE DATA WE
CAN BETTER ASSESS IF THE LAWS
WE PASS ARE ACTUALLY DOING WHAT
WE INTEND THEM TO DO. ACROSS
THE STATE. SB FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND IS RECEIVE NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MR BERMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THERE ARE. ALL MEMBERS BOTH.
HOME MEMBERS GO TO THIRTY A.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING HER EYES FIFTY FOUR NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WE
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY FOUR SB FOUR SEVENTY PER
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL FORCIBLY
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME AMERICA
RIO. IF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT US SENATE BILL
FOR SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
WIENER THESE ARE DOUBLE JOINTED
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS TRAPPED
IN CONFLICTS WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU'S AB TWO
FIFTEEN AN HOUR RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS CARILLO WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALTHOUGH SAY NO THE
AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT IN BCK ON
FILE. MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL MOVE BACK UP IN FILE ORDER
TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY ONE SB
FOUR FOUR SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL FOR FORTY
SEVEN BY CENTER LAYERED MACKLIN
SELECTIONS IT'S JUST ON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF CENTER LAYER. I
LIKE TO PRESENT AS BEFORE FORTY
SEVEN THIS IS A BILL. THAT
ALLOWS INJURED VICTIMS TO
RETAIN THEIR HUMAN SUFFERING.
DAMAGES EVEN IF THEY PASS AWAY.
PRIOR TO TRIAL THE M. SENATORS
TAKEN A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE REMOVED MOST OF THE
OPPOSITION AND I ASK FOR YOUR
ITEMS. THANK YOU MR STERN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. VERIFONE.
HOME MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE A-
THE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES FORTY
ONE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY TO
THIRTY VOTE THIS REQUIRES FORTY
ONE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE
A.
THIS IS DONE WITH THE CAR.
WE WILL PASS THIRTEEN FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY FIVE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY SIX SB FIVE
TWENTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY FOUR BY
SEVEN SKINNER AND OTHERS MIGHT
LIVE IN THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE DR EMILY ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL FIVE TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER WHICH HELPS TO
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS CAN USE
THEIR OWN PHARMACISTBY
PROHIBITING PATIENTS DURING.
ASIANS ARE SAFER AND BETTER
SERVED WHEN THEY CAN FILL THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS WITH PHARMACISTS.
WHO THEY HAVE A LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIP AND WHO KNOW THEIR
MEDICAL HISTORY AND SPEAK BOTH
THEIR LANGUAGE AND UNDERSTAND
CULTURAL SENSITIVITIES. BUT
PATIENTS CAN BE STEERED AWAY
FROM THEIR CHOSEN PHARMACIST
ONE OF PHARMACISTS BENESCH
BENEFIT MANAGER. INFORMS THEM
THAT THEY MUST FILL THEIR
PRESCRIPTION BY A PARTICULAR
PHARMACY. USUALLY A RETAIL OR
MAIL ORDER PHARMACY. OR TO PAY
OUT OF POCKET. SB FIVE TWENTY
FOUR PROHIBITS PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGERS FROM REQUIRING
PATIENTS. TO GO TO A PARTICULAR
PHARMACY WHEN THERE'S NO
CLINICAL REASON. TO DO SO.
INSURING PATIENTS CAN ACCESS
WHICHEVER PHARMACY THEY PREFER
WITHIN THEIR NETWORK. THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY DOCTORS BY
NURSES BY UFCW. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DR EMBARRASSING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE IT. ON MEMBERS THIRTY
TO THIRTY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
BUT THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE-
ALL MEMBERS VOTER RESERVE A
DOCTOR A MILLIMETER CALL.
FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY SEVEN SB FIVE
THIRTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY FOUR BY
SUE JONES NECKLACE IN HEALING
ARTS MR JANUARY NICE ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR CHAN. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTED ARTICLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY THREE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES WILL
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
ONE NINETY EIGHT THROUGH TWO
HUNDRED. FILE ITEM TO- ONE SB
FIVE SEVENTY THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SOONER JONES AND I
PLAY THE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR JONES I'M-
HAPPY TO RISE RESENT HIS BILL.
WHICH HELPS SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN THE
LANTERN IN PEACHTREE A BILL IT
IS A SIGNIFICANT BILL THAT THAT.
THE HELP SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE FOLKS SURVIVE SOME
OF THE- THE. THE
CONSERVATORSHIP SAID I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MR
STERN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. ALL
MEMBERS ARE THERE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A. WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT
ICE FIFTY NINE TWO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TO A TWO
ONE TWO THREE MOVING A FILE
ITEM TWO OH FOUR SB SIX OH SIX
FOR PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL SIX
OF SIX MINUTES BY SOME MEMBER
KALRA THIS RECOVERY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS. THANK THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THE MINISTER
SENATE BILL SIX OH SIX MAKE
TACTICAL CHANGES THE
TERMINOLOGY OF EGREGIOUS
VIOLATIONS AND CLARIFY
OBLIGATIONS. FOR MULTI EMPLOYER
WORK SITES. THE THESE IN A
REMOVE LAW CALL- AND FORCE
DIVISION FIVE LIVE BECAUSE-
REMOVAL REMOVES REQUIREMENTS ON
CAL OSHA TO ENFORCE SUBPOENAS.
AND EXEMPTS MULTI EMPLOYER WORK
SITES FROM INCLUDING A GREGIS
HISTORY DURING THE PRE
QUALIFICATION BETTER PROCESS.
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER WITHOUT
OBJECTION- TOOK A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO. THE
AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO BRING HIM BACK
ON FILE. PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE PASSED A
ROUTINE AND FILE ITEM TWO OF
THE SIX. THROUGH. TO TEN. MOVE.
WE'LL NEED TO FILE ITEM TO
ELEVEN SB SIX FIFTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
654% OF MEN AND OTHERS MACKLIN
SHALL CUSTODY MAYES RUBIO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB FIVE AT SIX
FIFTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR MAN SB SIX
FIFTY FOUR IS A CRUCIAL MEASURE
MEASURE THAT CREATES NEW
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS AND EXTENDS
EXISTING SAFEGUARDS FOR
CHILDREN IN FAMILY COURT
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL DOES TWO
THINGS FIRST SB SIX FIFTY FOUR
PREVENTS THE CHILD'S TESTIMONY
FROM BEING GIVEN IN THE
PRESENCE OF PARTY SEEKING
CUSTODY SUCH AS THE CHILD'S
PARENTS UNLESS IT IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. CHILDREN HAVE A
RIGHT TO BE HEARD IN CUSTODY
AND THEY SHOULD BE HEARD IN A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT SECONDLY SB
SIX FIFTY FOUR TAKES EXISTING
SAFETY MEASURES USED RELATED TO
CHILD CUSTODY DETERMINATION
EXPENSE THEM TO UNSUPERVISED
VISITATION SPECIFICALLY IT
ENSURES THAT JUDGES CONSIDER
HIS HISTORIES OF ABUSE AND
ADDICTION WHEN MAKING CUSTODY
DETERMINATIONS THIS IS A
CRITICAL MEASURE THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT THE SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN ARE TOP
PRIORITIES IN CONTENTION A
CONTENTIOUS CUSTODY BATTLES
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISS RUBIO.
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN ALL MEMBERS
MOSTLY DESERTED THE- ALL
MEMBERS GO WHO DESERVE IT.
BURKE WELL FOODS THE ROLLING
TALITA I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS AND RETAIN
AND FILE ITEM TO TWELVE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
TO THIRTEEN PASS AND RETAIN A
FILE ITEMS TO FOURTEEN THROUGH
TO SIXTEEN. TEMPORARILY
AVAILABLE. TO SEVENTEEN. WE
WILL PASS A RETAINER FILE ITEM.
TWO EIGHTEEN INTO NINETEEN
MOVING THE FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
SB SEVEN SEVENTY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY SIX BY SOONER GONZALEZ
AND I PLAYED IN THE WATER.
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER THANK YOU MA'AM
SPEAKER IN CALLING THIS BILL
MAKE VARIOUS STATUTORY CHANGES
TO ENHANCE THE STATE WATER
BOARDS ABILITY. TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
IMPLEMENT THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER ACT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TWO
THIRDS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
ARTICLE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TELEVOTE EYES FORTY TWO
KNOWS TWELVE THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MR STONE IS PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE
NINETEEN NO ONE NINETY ONE SB
FOUR FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE
A. ALL MEMBERS AGES ARE DIVERT
THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FORTY TWO
KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
TO TWENTY ONE SB SEVEN NINETY
THE- SENATE BILL 790% OF STERN
AND OTHER CYCLING OFFICIAL
MALAI. MR GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. I
THINK YOU MEANT THREE KERN
COLLEAGUES SB SEVEN NINETY BY.
SENATOR STERN. WHAT CREATED YOU
CAN COMPENSATE TERRY MITIGATION%
CREDIT PROGRAM AT CDFW FOR
CALTRANS PROJECTS TO IMPROVE
WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF THE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL ME THAT I SIXTY SEVEN
NEWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS SEVENTEEN ON FILE
ITEM TWO TWENTY TWO WE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY HIGHLIGHTED TO
TWENTY THREE. A PATH TO RETAIN
A FILE ITEM TO TWENTY FOUR
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
FIVE SB EIGHT OH SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
IT'LL SEVEN BUCKS IN A ROW CAL
SCHEMATICALLY IN CIVIL RIGHTS
IF YOU'RE TO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB EIGHT OH SEVEN
ADDRESSES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING WAS
TASKED WITH THE OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT OF MANY OF OUR
STATES OF RIGHTS LAWS. IN THE
EIGHT YEARS DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
PROSECUTING CIVIL RIGHTS ACTION
STAKEHOLDERS OF IDENTIFIED
SECTIONS OF THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ACT IN NEED OF
MODERNISATION HARMONIZATION AND
CLARIFICATION. THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THOSE ISSUES IMPROVE
GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY. AND
PROVIDES THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ACT WITH GREATER
CLARITY. AND ORGANIZATION
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
IDOL. THANK YOU MR CHIU SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. HOME
NUMBER THIRTY DESERVE A. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE HIGHS FIFTY TWO NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES WILL
PASS AND RETAIN AND VIOLENCE.
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHT. MEMBERS WERE GONNA BACK
UP IN FILE ORDERED TO FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN. SB FIVE
EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY NINE BY
CENTER HUESO AND OTHERS MACKLIN
AIR POLLUTION. MR GARCIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER
YES MY SPEAKER IN COLLEAGUES-
THESE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS.
ATTENTIONAL CHAPTER IN ISSUES
WITH OTHER STATUTES RESPECT AS
RIVAL THANK YOU. OKAY TO KEEP.
MR GARCIA DO AMENDMENTS IN
FRONT OF YOU I DO I HAVE
AMENDMENTS AND I ALSO HAVE THE
BILL 2% OF HIS BODY CHOOSES TO
SUPPORT THE AMENDMENTS. SIX
ABSOLUTELY WE DON'T APPEAR TO
HAVE THOSE AMENDMENT AT THE
DESK. OKAY WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY IN THIS ITEM. THANK
YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO THE CONCURRENCE
ITEMS. AGAIN I ASK THAT EVEN
ITEM ON CONCURRENCE. WE HAVE
NOW WE'VE TO THE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR RULE ON ALL ITEMS FILE
ITEM SEVEN THROUGH FIFTY ONE I.
ATHEY PLEASE BE YOUR JACKSON
READY PRESENT YOUR BILL SO WE
CAN MOVE THROUGH THE
CONCURRENCE FILE. HAVING TO
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB SIXTY SIX
THE KERKORIAN. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTY SIX PRICE MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND OTHERS NEKO
NICHOLS RESOURCES
BOERNER HORVATH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB SIXTY SIX REQUIRES
SCRIPT INSTITUTION OF
OCEANOGRAPHY AT UC SAN DIEGO.
TO CONDUCT A RESEARCH STUDY TO
IMPROVE CLOSELY MONITORING
CAPABILITIES. AND OBSERVATIONS
THAT SAYS THE STATE'S
DEVELOPMENT OF THE COASTAL
BLUFFS EARLY WARNING
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM. THE SENATE
MEMBERS LIMIT THE UC REGENTS
EXEMPTION FOR CIVIL LIABILITY
FOR ANY HARM RESULTING FROM
MEASUREMENT PREDICTIONS OR
WARNINGS. REGARDING BLOOD
FAILURE CLIFF WHEN FUNDS ARE
RUSSIAN TO ONLY GOOD FAITH
OPTIONS IMAGE WITH THE MISSIONS
OF CONSTITUTING. GROSS THAT
DILUTES NEGLIGENCE FROM
EXEMPTION THE BILL HAS SUPPORT
FROM BOTH SIDES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON. CONCURRENCE THANK YOU
MISS BERNARD ABOUT. MISTER
BENNETT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. YOU KNOW HOW MISTER
BENNETT I DON'T WANT TO DIRECT.
SO SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE WILL- OPEN THEIR OWN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TWO THIRDS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE
TO VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT I FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS ONE SEVEN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM NINE AB ONE TENTACLE REACH.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TEN BY SOME
RIVER REGION NORRIS AND OTHERS
NOT QUITE ON POINT INSURANCE TO
TURNER'S CEDAR THE CORRECT
IMMEDIATELY. IN ORDER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOUMADAM
SPEAKER AB ONE TEN IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE. THIS
IS THE COMMONSENSE MEASURE TO
PREVENT FRAUD AT CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. HI THE AMENDED BILL
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS PETRI
NORRIS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE IT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO. OUR
MEMBERS VOTED ABOUT THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO.
MOVED TO TAKE UP THE SPEAKER
PRO TEM'S ITEMS WE WILL START
WITH FILE ITEM TO AB TEN TWENTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN AND
OTHERS NOT GOING TO HOUSING
COMMITTEE TO SIT UP THE CORRECT
IMMEDIATELY THROWING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. AN AMENDMENT
IN THE SENATE ADDING MISTER
GABRIEL'S A CO AUTHOR. IS WHY
THIS IS ON CONCURRENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN
WITH SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON ADDING MR
GABRIEL. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTED EITHER
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE IT REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR
TO ADD MR GABRIEL AS A CO
AUTHOR. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. YES- ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY TO THEIR TO VOTE. THIRTY
WALDRON. PERHAPS MR GABRIEL
WOULD LIKE TO VOTE. CREEK ROAD
CLOSED THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES HIGHS FIFTY FIVE NEWS
FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORDANT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FIVE AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME LEGAL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY SOME OF OUR
MULLIN AND ACCIDENTS DRIVERS
LICENSES MISTER MIND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MASS
SPEAKER SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
THE DMV AND- DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIA HAVE ENJOYED A
STATUTORILY ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIP WERE CALIFORNIANS
OF PLAYING FOR DRIVER'S LICENSE
RIGHT THE ARE ALSO ASKED IF
THEY'D LIKE TO ROLL IN THE
ORGAN AND TISSUE. TRANSPLANT
REGISTRY. HOWEVER CALIFORNIANS
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER IN ROLE
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR WILL WILL
ALLOW THE DMV AND DONATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA TO ENTER INTO AN MO
YOU. TO UPDATE THE DONATION
QUESTION ACCORDING TO BEST
PRACTICES THAT I ASKED FOR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
MISTER MULLIN SINGING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO BOTH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE BOTH
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY FIVE
NEW ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIX EIGHTY NINE FIFTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME OF THE
NINE FIFTY NINE BY SOME OF OUR
MULLIN AND OTHER SNACK WITH A
PARK DISTRICTS IS YOUR MAILING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. AND FINALLY
MADAM SPEAKER AB NINE FIFTY
NINE WOULD SIMPY ALLOW
INDEPENDENT PARK DISTRICTS TO
BE ABLE TO EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS A MULTITUDE
OF PUBLIC NUISANCES THAT THEY
CONFRONT REGULARLY. AMENDMENTS
FOR CLARIFYING TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AFTER AN AYE VOTE ON
THINKER THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL
OPEN THE- CALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ON THE VOTED
VERY. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY
FIVE NEWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN S. AB FIVE
SEVENTY THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY BY
SOME REMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS NOT GOING TO HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE MR SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I THINK IMMENSELY
BECAUSE BILLS BACK FROM CURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENT FOR TECHNICAL
IN NATURE AND THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW CHILDREN OUT OF THE KIND
OF PARENTS. TO THE HEALTH
INSURANCE- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED ESERVER. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
THE VOTE. DID. BURKE WILL RE
OPEN. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THAT EYES FORTY ONE
KNOWS THIRTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FIVE TO DONE BY SOMEONE
ARAMBULA AND ACTUALLY THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB FIVE FIVE NINE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR AN IBM. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. CALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. NUMBER
THIRTY TWO ZERO BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE ICE
FORTY EIGHT NEWS NINE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN WE
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY AB SIX
HUNDRED TO QUICKLY ASSEMBLE SIX
HUNDRED BISON REMEMBER ARAMBULA
ENACTED IN A CRIMES. AFTER A
ARE ACTING NOTICED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER SB SIX HUNDRED IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE AND AMENDMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ANOTHER.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- CALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTEEN OH
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB SIX FOURTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME OF THE
L. SIX FOURTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY NOT
PLAYING THE WILDLIFE HABITAT
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB SIX
FOURTEEN IS BACK OPEN CURRENTS
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TAKEN SENT
ENSURE FUNDING TO THE NESTING
BIRD HABITAT INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
TRANSCRIBER THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALZHEIMER'S VOTE. HOME VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER TO VOTE THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT NEW ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING A FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY SIX THIRTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL SIX
THIRTY SIX BY SUMMER
MAIENSCHEIN ACKLIN ELDER OR
DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE REMAIN
TRYING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB SIXTY SIX
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN ITEM.
THANK YOU MR MAIENSCHEIN SINGH
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE RUN. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE A BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE RULING TALIBAN I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX FIFTY TWO THE
PERFORATED SOME AGO SIX FIFTY
TWO BY SUMMER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS NOT QUITE IN PRODUCT
SAFETY FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AMENDMENTS
MADE TO AB SIX FIFTY TWO. IN
THE SENATE WHERE TECHNICAL AND
NOT SUBSTANTIVE IN NATURE HE
BILL AS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES IT
IS NO OPPOSITION TO PASS THE
SENATE WITH A BI PARTISAN.
THIRTY TWO ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. HOME MEMBERS GO
TO DESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE A. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THEIR EYES
FORTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING THE FILE ITEM WE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR. MOVED TO A FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX
NINETY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME LEGAL SIX NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOW
AND OTHERS BACK WITHIN FOUR
STREET. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER- AB SIXTY SEVEN IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHOW SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTIES ERA BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT
ICE FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN WE
WILL MOVE BACK UP TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY
FOUR. THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
BILLS SIX SEVENTY FOUR BY SOME
MEMBER BENNETT MACULATUM
JUVENILES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- EIGHTY
SIX- SEVENTY FOUR IS BACK IN
THE ASSEMBLY FOR CONCURRENCY
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
I WERE FREE FOR CHAPARRAL
PURPOSES. OF THE BILLS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND THAT HAS
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE. OUR MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESERVE IT. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN THE BACK IN
FILE ORDER FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ CYNICAL SEVEN
TWENTY ONE BY SUMMER BLOOMING
ACTED IN REAL PROPERTY THEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AB
SEVEN TWENTY ONE THIS YEAR ON
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE CLARIFY
THAT A PROPERTY OWNER. MUST
RECORD A MODIFICATION DOCUMENTS
TO UTILIZE THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL
OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THIRTY. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DESERVE IT. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY THAT ICE
FORTY THREE KNOWS FIFTEEN.
SENATE IN THE BACK OF THE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED
IN. FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
SEVEN FORTY SIX MONTHS MEMBERS
OF ARTISTICALLY INTO ADOPTION
THIS AROUND IF YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SEVEN FOUR
SIX REMOVE EXISTING BARRIERS
THAT HINDER AND PROLONG THE
STEPPARENT ADOPTION PROCESS FOR
FAMILIES ESPECIALLY LGBTQ
FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AIBO ON CONCURRENCE ON SENATE
MEMBERS FOR AB. SEVEN FOUR SIX.
THANK YOU MESS AROUND TO IS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. ALL MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD
OF. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD
ABOUT THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE WILL MOVE
BACK UP IN FILE ORDERED TO FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB THIRTY THREE. THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
THIRTY THREE BY SOMEBODY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TUNING AND
OTHER SACRAMENTO ENERGY IN
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR
RESEARCHING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THIRTY THREE IS BACK ON THE
CURRENT STATE OF THE BAND'S
ADDED NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES. FOR ENERGY
CONSERVATION ASSISTANCE ACT
LOANS AS WELL AS CREATE A SUB
ACCOUNT WITHIN- THE LOAN TO
TRACK LOWER PAYMENTS THE BILL'S
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER KING THING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
BURKE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO GO. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED ESERVER CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT I SIXTY
TWO NEW ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE WILL MOVE
UP IN FILE ORDER. TO FILE ITEM
FORTY NINE. AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
TO THE CORPORATION. SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO BISON THE
MARKETING AND OTHER RESPECTED
IN THE JURY'S THIRTEEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MEMBERS BE
GRAVY FORTY FIFTY TWO WAS BACK
ON THE CURRENT SYSTEM IN THE
SENATE. DID NOT OUT PEOPLE THAT
THE PILOT PROGRAM CALLED B. THE
JURY FOR LOW TO MODERATE INCOME
JURORS ARE COMPENSATED ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER DAY FOR
JURY SERVICE IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO SUPERIOR COURT. THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU MISTER KING
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
MODE. HOME MEMBERS GO TO DESERT
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD
ABOUT THE PARK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THAT I SIXTY ONE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COMPARED IN. THAT'S ARAMBULA IS
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SIX SB
FIVE TWENTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FORTY FIVE NEWS SIX THAT
MEASURE PASSES. LIVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT WE'RE BACK ON
THE CONCURRENT FILE IN FILE
ORDER EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
SEVEN FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN AND OTHERS
TACKLING VITAL RECORDS. IS-
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED- THANK
YOU AB SEVEN FIVE ONE IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE OF THE
AMENDMENTS CREATE A THREE YEAR
BIOMETRICS MORATORIUM AND ADD
PRIVACY PROVISIONS HI I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK YOU
MISS IRWIN SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED AMERICA. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE FOR WELL
CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY THAT IS
FIFTIES HIGH SIXTY NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORDANT WE'RE GONNA FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND
OTHERS BACK LATE IN THE VOTER
REGISTRATION BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB
SEVENTY SIX SIX TO IMPROVE AND
REFINE THE CALIFORNIA NEW MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM. TO ENSURE ITS
CONTINUED SUCCESS AND
EFFECTIVENESS SENATE AMENDMENTS
ADDED CLARIFYING LANGUAGE TO
FURTHER ENSURE THAT ONLY
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS ARE
REGISTERED TO VOTE DELAYED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TO PROVISIONS
TO ALIGN WITH THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT THE DMV WILL BE ONBOARDING
OVER TE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS
ELIMINATE DUPLICATIVE NOTICES
AND ADDRESS CHATTERING ISSUES.
OUR SERVICE RUN AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MR BERMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL
OPEN. THE RUN. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIGN IT. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE BETTER.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLIED ABOUT ICE FORTY NINE
NEWS SEVENTEEN SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY AB- FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ SOMETHING FOR BY THIS
MEMBER MEGAN DALY AND OTHERS
NOT GOING TO HUNTING STYLE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AB EIGHT OH FOUR IS
BACK ON CURRENTS FROM THE
SENATE WITH TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER ALI SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THERE TO VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
VOTED IS ERICA. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED ESERVER. BURKE WILL LOSE
THEIR ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE I
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS FOR SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY FOURTH
CIRCLE RATE SOME PEOPLE HE
TWENTY FOUR BY SUMMER BUT
BENNETT ENACTED IN LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES MISTER
MANNING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AB EIGHT TWENTY FORCED BACK
FROM THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE
OF THE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. THE BILL NOW
HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I'VE
TAKEN THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ARTICLE.
HOME MEMBER THOSE WHO IT. HOME
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE BOTH.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COMPARED IN MOVING A FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO AB EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS NOT GOING
TO BUILDING STANDARDS. THREE
MEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS MADE TO AB EIGHT
THIRTY AT THE SENATE AND FOR
THAT LANDLORDS ARE NOT CHARGED
FOR BASIS INSPECTIONS. BUT ALSO
MAINTAINING A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
EXISTING FEE OF THIRTY. TO
RECUPERATE FUNDS FOR
INSPECTIONS THROUGH GENERAL
FEET. TO CLARIFY THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT IMPOSE A MANDATORY
DUTY OR COULD BE CONSTRUED TO
AFFECT ANY IMMUNITY. OTHERWISE
APPLICABLE TO A CITY OR COUNTY
UNDER EXISTING LAW I WOULD
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE AND I
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED ALREADY VOTED.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. HOME NUMBER THIRTY THIRD
OF A. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY TWO
KNOWS EIGHTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN- IN
A FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME PEOPLE NINE THIRTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE
INACTIVE AND EXCAVATIONS. MR
GREEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS OR
MODIFY OUR TECHNICAL AND-
MINIMAL AND- MAKE THE BILL
BETTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
LEVINE. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AMERICA. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
THE VOTE IS FORTY TWO KNOWS
TWELFTH AND AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THE PAST RETAIN A
FLE ITEM THIRTY FOUR UNIFIL
AND THIRTY FIVE MAYBE TEN TEN
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
MIDDLETON TEN BY THIS MEMBER
BERMAN AND ACTIVE IN THE
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN COLLEAGUES
AB TEN TEN WHICH IS SPONSORED
BY THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS. REQUIRES THAT
ARCHITECTS COMPLETE FIVE HOURS
OF ZERO NET CARBON CONTINUING
THAT EDUCATION FOR TWO YEAR
LICENSE RENEWAL CYCLE
SENTIMENTS CLARIFY THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS AND RELATED
REGULATIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE IN
SENTIMENTS. THANK YOU MR BERMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. HOME
NUMBER SAID DESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SERVICE THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX AB TEN TWENTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN TWENTY ONE BY THE SOME
INFORMATION I PUT IN IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS AND CLARITY OF CEDAR
OF TECH THE COMPLETELY MR MAYS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER- AB TEN TWENTY
ONE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE JUST
WANTED TO TAKE. A MOMENT TO
ONCE AGAIN I THANK THE CHAIR OF
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE-
AND ALSO MY PARTNER- IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY A FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS SO WE KNOW. THAT
IS UNACCEPTABLE- THAT 60% OF
THE PEOPLE IN THE LOGICAL
SERVICES AREA DO NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT. TO BE ABLE TO VOTE FOR
SOMEBODY ON A MEMBER OF THE
GOVERNING BOARD THIS IS BEEN A
PROBLEM- FOR. THAT FOR DECADES-
AND IT'S- SO THIS IS ONE STEP
IN THE PROCESS TO CREATE A
LOCAL PROCESS HAVE A LAUGH GOES
A CONTINUE TO DO THIS WORK
PROVIDING THEM GUIDANCE. HERE
TO RESPECT THE REQUEST AND I
HOPE. THANK YOU MISTER MAZINGER.
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERTED BOTH
WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW IT ABOUT I. SIXTY KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I SIXTEEN
IS THERE ON THE MEASURE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN AB TEN
SIXTY FOUR THE KERKORIAN
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG ACCOLADE
IN THE PHARMACY FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. AB TEN SIXTY FOURS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW PHARMACISTS TO
INDEPENDENTLY INITIATE AND
ADMINISTER VACCINES APPROVED BY
THE FDA INCIDENT AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THOSE VACCINES MUST
ALSO RECEIVE A RECOMMENDATION.
FROM THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR FONG SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED EITHER. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE VOTE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALENTED I SIXTY TWO NEW ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT AB TEN SIXTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
TEN SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AND OTHERS TACKLING THE
WATER QUALITY. MR LYNN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TEN SIXTY SIX IS
HERE ON CONCURRENCE. AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN IN THE SENATE TO AND
EXTEND THE TIMELINE FOR THE
WATER MONITORING COUNCIL. TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD BASED OFF OF
THE ESTABLISHED WORKING GROUP'S
FINDINGS. THUS MAKING THIS A
TWO STEP PROCESS. ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS AT THE REQUEST OF
THE STATE WATER BORDER
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING IN
NATURE THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION IN A RISK.
THANKFULLY AFTER ARRIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER BLOOM THING EARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE THIRD OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO GO. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY THREE NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORDANT LUNA FILE ITEM
THIRTY NINE AB TWENTY TWO FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND OTHERS
NATALIE IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
HELLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BEEN A SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR LOW SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED ARTICLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS
THIRTEEN SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FORTY AB TEN NINETY FOUR
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
TO NINETY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA AND OTHERS BACK
ON THE HEALTH DATA COLLECTION
DOCTOR. RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TEN
NINETY FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCERNS AND SENATE AMENDMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MICHAEL.
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE- OF THE TWO
THIRDS VOTE. HOME MEMBERS GO TO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
THIRD. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY
EIGHT NEW ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN WITHIN A FILE
ITEM FORTY ONE EIGHTY ELEVEN-
FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY RELIVING BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AFTER
THEIR INFANT SERVICES NUCLEAR
ZERO SIX ADMITTEDLY GRAYSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB ELEVEN ZERO FOUR IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
TEMPORARILY EXTENDING EMERGENCY
MEDICAL AIR TRANSPORTATION ACT
TO CONTINUE TO SUPPLEMENT AIR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS AT CURRENT
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND THEN
PROVIDES A REIMBURSEMENT RATE.
INCREASE IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
INCORPORATED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN AND UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE RAW. NUMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF THE-
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THERE I SIXTY FOUR NEW
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING A FILE ITEM FORTY TWO
AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME OF THE LIVING
FORTY SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS NOT GONNA
TRANSITION PLANNING THREE WHEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS
TO CONCUR IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WOULD REMOVE REMOVE
ALL NON OPPOSITION TO THIS VERY
GOOD BILL HELPS GET MONEY TO
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE-
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION SAFER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL WUSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY
KNOWS FOURTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN WE
TO FILE ITEM FORTY THREE AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME OF THE LIMON
SEVENTY FOUR BY US IMMIGRATION
ACT LIVING A HOUSING DECLARE
THERE'S EITHER OF SIGNIFICANTLY.
MISTER RACING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE ALLOWING
QUALIFIED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
PROJECTS EFFECTIVELY
STREAMLINED HOUSING AND
DEVELOPMENT AS INTENDED UNDER
CURRENT LAW. SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY WHEN CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES CONSIDERED TO BEGAN
STATE THAT THE EXTENDED STRUCK
A SHOT CLOCK FOR ALL FOR A
MODIFICATION APPROVAL ONLY
APPLIES TO THE FIRST. PROJECT
MODIFICATION AND SPECIFIED RICK
AFFORDABILITY FOR PROJECTS
ABOVE A CERTAIN SIZE AN URGENCY
CLAUSE WAS ADDED IN THE SENATE.
THIS MEASURE HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I'VE- THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED ESERVER. WHERE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE NEWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY FIVE NEWS HERE
ON THE MEASURE THAT MEASURE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR AB TWELVE TWENTY TWO
THIRTY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN AND I PUT IN THE
CANNABIS. CAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THIS BILL BACK ON
CONCERNS DUE TO TECHNICAL
LIMITS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHANCING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED ARTICLE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND HOW YOU KNOW WHAT
I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED AND WE
TO FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ CYNICAL TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
BY SUMMER BLOOM AND OTHERS
SPECULATE IN ANIMAL HEALTH
MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO IS HERE ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE CHANGE THE TRIGGER
FOR THE PHASE OUT OF CLOSE
COLONIES. BY ELIMINATING
RETROACTIVE REPORTING A BLOOD
SOLD AND REPLACING IT WITH THE
FORWARD LOOKING APPROACH
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS INSURED
BLOOD IMPORTED FROM OUT OF
STATE IS ONLY FROM COMMUNITY
BLOOD BANKS AND NOT BLOOD BANK
STILL OPERATING UNDER THE
CLOSED QUALITY MODEL AND LASTLY
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
PERTAINING TO YOUR REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND FEES THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ONCE AGAIN. AS FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM SEEING HEARING NOFURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED EITHER. ALL MEMBERS TO IS
ARTICLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE.
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND
OTHERS BACK OVER THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR MR HOLDEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE A. B.
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN WILL
QUALIFY THAT THE AYE BIG MAY
FINANCE HOUSING AS A PART OF AN
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE PROJECT ONLY
WHEN THE HOUSING ELEMENT IS
REQUIRED FOR THE OPERATION OF
THE PROJECT. THE MEMBERS OF
THIS BILL SIMPLY ADD A CO
AUTHOR TWELVE NINETY SEVEN HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN. SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THIRD. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
AMERICA. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
THIRD OF THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO THE
CRITICAL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHALLENGE ACTED
IN INFORMATION SECURITY MISTER
CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY TWO IS PACKED FULL
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE MEMBERS
WOULD ALLOW THE STATE
CYBERSECURITY INTEGRATION
CENTER TO CONSULT THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT I'M PROVIDING
ASSESSMENTS TO ELEAZAR AND
OBTAIN THE RESULTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHOW SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER BURKE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE
A- HOME MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO
GO. ALL MEMBERS OF OUR TO VOTE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I SIXTY FOUR NEW
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARKAN
PRUDENT WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
IN FILE ITEMS FORTY EACH WE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE PASS TEMPORARILY OF
VIOLATING FIFTY MOVIE TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY ONE. EIGHTY FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION AND
ACTIVE IN THE HORSERACING. MR
FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS. AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN IS DANIEL ASSEMBLY
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE BUILDING MAKES
CLARIFYING. AND NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO
STATUTE. THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD
TO POST THE PUBLIC RECORD OF
EVERY VOTE ON ITS INTERNET.
INTERNET WEBSITE. ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL WILL ENSURE ONGOING
PROTECTION TO THE INTEGRITY OF
THE U. CH ARBY'S. ACTIVITIES
AND REDUCE THE RISK OF FRAUD BY
THE WAY OF EXPLICIT STATUTORY
AUTHORITY. FOR THE BOARD TO
RECEIVE CRIMINAL HISTORY
INFORMATION FOR PROSPECTIVE
EMPLOYEES CONTRACTORS AND
LICENSES. TO MAKE
DETERMINATIONS OF FITNESS FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS. THIS BILL
WILL HELP ENSURE THE PUBLIC
AWARE OF THE ACTIONS TAKEN BY
THE C. H. R. B. WOODS PROMOTES
OPENNESS AND HAS PUT
TRANSPARENT TRANSPARENCY IN
DECISION MAKING. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE IN
CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU MISTER
FRAZIER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER. DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
HOME VOTE THIRD OF. ALL MEMBERS
ROAD DESERVE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLLING I SIXTY NEWS
CENTER AMENDMENTS CAN IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK THE SENATE FILE FOUR.
AMENDMENTS. WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM TO SEVENTEEN
SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY ONE WITH A MINUTES BY
SOME MEMBER BETWEEN THIRTEEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU I-
RISING PERCENT AMENDMENTS TO
THE SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR DRAWS OF THE AMENDMENT
TO DRESS CHOPPING ISSUES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR TANG SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED
SAY NO THE AYES HAVE AT THE
MOMENT THIRD OPTED OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE
WILL BE AN ENTERTAINING VOTE
CHANGES AT THIS TIME IF YOU OF
THE CHANGE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE JUST RAISE YOUR MIKE.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH MISTER LEE'S.
HELLO OUR VOTE CHANGES
SIMILARLY FILE ITEM THIRTY AB
EIGHT OH FOUR I SAID NO THANK
YOU MISTER LEE MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN OH WAIT NO RIGHT
PLEASE REMOVE CHANGED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE ASSEMBLY WILL IT'LL
FOR I TO KNOW. THANK YOU MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN THANK THANK YOU
MADAM SEAKER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
I TO NOT VOTING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN SYMBOL SEVEN
TWENTY ONE I DO NOT VOTING.
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER- SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE
NINE FROM I CANNOT NOTING.
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT
SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY NINE I
DO NOT VOTING IS FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE
NINE I DO NOT VOTING. CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY NINE I TO NOT
LOADING. DR CHOI STEVEN CHOI
FILE NUMBER THIRTY NINE AB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR NO TO NOT FORTY.
WELL CHANGES IN THE RIVER CHOI
SOME BUILT IN EIGHTY FOUR NO TO
NOT VOTING.
WE'RE GONNA DO ONE
MORE VOTE CHANGER WALDRON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER- FILE
NUMBER TWO AB TEN TWENTY NINE I
TO NOT VOTING. WALDRON CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY NINE I
TO NOT LOAD. OKAY.
MEMBERS WE
ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
AND AGUIAR-CURRY IS PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE
NINETEEN S. B. FIVE TEN THE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND- WHO NEEDS. OUR
MEMBERS VALUE THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF IT
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR. WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE EYES FORTY FIVE NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE FAILS IS
AGUIAR-CURRY MOVES
RECONSIDERATION. TRANSACTION.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEM TO TEN SB SIX FORTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY SIX BY CENTER
HERTZBERG ACCORDING TO
EMPLOYMENT ISRAEL'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER. THE
JANITORIAL SERVICES INDUSTRY IS
CURRENTLY DRIVEN BY INTENSE
COMPETITION FOR CONTRACTS MY
JANITORIAL SERVICE FIRMS. ON
THE PREVAILING TO MULTIPLE
CHAINS OF LOW ROAD
SUBCONTRACTING. LOW LABOR COSTS
ARE THE PRIMARY GROUND ON WHICH
LOW ROAD GEN GEND TORY OLD
CONTRACTORS COMPETE FOR
BUSINESS NOT INNOVATION OR
PRODUCTIVITY. THESE LOW ROAD
EMPLOYERS. AND TOO OFTEN ENGAGE
IN EGREGIOUS WAGE AND
EMPLOYMENT VIOLATIONS FOR
JANITORIAL WORKERS. THIS
UNFORTUNATE REALITY SEVERELY
LIMITS THE ABILITY OF UNIONIZED
RESPONSIBLE CONTRACTORS FROM
SHIFTING THE COMPETITION THE
COOLEY REMOVE THE INDUSTRY
TOWARD A HIGH ROAD MODEL BASED
ON QUALITY RATHER THAN SIMPLY
CUTTING COSTS. SB SIX FORTY SIX
ATTEMPTS TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR RESPONSIBLE
CONTRACTORS AND THEIR WORKERS
BY EXEMPTING ZACH JANITORIAL
EMPLOYEES FOR PAGA IF THE
EMPLOYEES WORK IS COVERED BY A
VALID COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT. THIS BILL SUPPORTS
AND ADVANCES THE COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS OF HIGH ROAD EMPLOYERS
AND WORKERS TO TRANSFORM THE
INDUSTRY AND LEMONADE
EXPLOITATION ABUSE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR.
HERTZBERG THANK YOU MISS RAY S.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
THIRD OF A. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE IS
FORTY NINE NEWS HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL TAKE A
FIFTY FIVE FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS. THE GREAT SENATE
BILL TWO FIFTY FIVE OF THE
MEMBERS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THAT THANK YOU HAVE A SPEAKER
MEMBERS AMENDMENTS TO SP TWO
FIFTY FIVE AYE SENATOR
PORTANTINO ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE INCLUDE CHATTERING OUT
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
QUESTION I. THINK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION TO TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THESE MOMENTS OLIVER SAY I'D
ALSO SAY NO THE AYES HAVE IT
THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED OUT TO
BRING THEM BACK ON FILE.
THIS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
THE CHANGE. THANK YOU AB EIGHT
OH FOUR I KNOW. BOTH CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ SYMBOL
IT'LL FOR I TO KNOW.
IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PREVIOUSLY
NASSER GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION IF
THE CALL. AND PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS COULD TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE COURT.
I'M NOT SURE YOU ALL HEARD ME
QUORUM CALL HAS BEEN LIFTED.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR SO
WE CAN MOVE TO THE ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MISTER BOLAN IS NOT DOING IT.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
THE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
pMEMBERS EVERY DAY THOUSANDS OF
MEN AND WOMEN RESTORE LIVES FOR
THE SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF
OUR CITIZENRY. THEY DO THIS OF
PRIDE SELFISHNESS IT WITHOUT
HESITATION TODAY I DURING THE
MEMORY OF OFFICER HER MENTOR
GREENWALD OF THE GULF POLICE
DEPARTMENT THE MIDFIELDER
SACRIFICE FROM AUGUST TWENTY
SEVENTH ONE OF THE WAY THE
SYSTEM THE DEVASTATING CALDOR
FIRE. CONTINUE FILMMAKING DELTA
COLLEGE POLICE ACADEMY IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OUR MENTOR
PREVIOUSLY WORKED FOR THE
MODESTO AND LODI POLICE
DEPARTMENTS BEFORE FINDING HIS
HOME AT THE GULF POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
TO TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF AGE
ALL THREE WALL WITH THE YOUNG
STAR ON THE RISE. IN THE GULF
POLICE DEPARTMENT. IN A SHORT
TIME THEIR REMOTE WAS PRESENTED
WITH A POLICE OFFICER OF THE
YEAR AWARD IN TWENTY TWENTY.
OSTERMANN DEGREE WALL
EXEMPLIFIED HONOR LOYALTY
INTEGRITY. MY HEARTFELT
CONDOLENCES AND PRAYERS GO OUT
TO HIS FAMILY FRIENDS AND
FELLOW OFFICERS. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
OFFICER HER MENTOR WE WILL.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER. MS
CLARK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN AND MEROM IN
MEMORY FOR LARRY HERMAN. FORMER
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF LA PALMA
LARRY HERMAN PASSED AWAY ON
AUGUST FIFTEENTH HE WAS THE
CITY OF LA PALMA S. LONGEST
SERVING COUNCIL MEMBER SERVING
A TOTAL OF SIXTEEN YEARS FROM.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX TO NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR AND ALSO
200-022-2000 TEN INCLUDING TWO
TERMS AS MAYOR. AS A LA PALMA
HOME HOMEOWNER SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR LARRY CONTINUALLY
TOOK PRIDE IN THE CITY AND
HELPING OUT AT HIS RESIDENCE I
OFTEN REMEMBER HER M. SCENE I
AM AT THE FOURTH OF JULY PARADE
WORKING TO SERVE PANCAKES HE
ALSO COMMITTED HIS LIFE TO
COMMUNITY SERVICE HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS. AS A
NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH DISTRICT
COORDINATOR MEALS ON WHEELS
VOLUNTEER ORANGE COUNTY VECTOR
CONTROL TRUSTEE AND A MEMBER OF
THE QANTAS CLUB OF LA PALMA ARE
TRULY REMARKABLE. LARRY WAS
SELECTED AS THE PROMISED
NINETEEN NINETY SIX AMERICANA
AWARDS CITIZEN OF THE YEAR
PRESENTED BY THE CYPRESS
COLLEGE FOUNDATION. IN
RECOGNITION OF HIS COMMUNITY
SERVICE LARRY IS ALSO ACTIVE
WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY INCLUDING VOLUNTEERING
IN THE ROAD TO RECOVERY AND
DAFFODIL DAYS PROGRAMS AS WELL
AS THE ANNUAL RELAY FOR LIFE
EVENT. IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR
FOUR LARRY WAS PRESENTED WITH
THE LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AWARD
FROM THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY. LARRY IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE OF NEARLY SIXTY YEARS
WILLA AND SON MICHAEL HE WILL
BE REMEMBERED FOR THE PRIDE HE
TOOK IN HIS PUBLIC SERVICE AND
GREATLY MISSED BY THOSE WHO
WERE AFFECTED BY HIS ACTS OF
KINDNESS. I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISS CLARK SILVA IS RUBIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO HONOR
THE MEMORY OF ANTHONY DAMIEN.
TONY WAS BORN ON AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTH NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
AND LOS ANGELES ALIFORNIA TO
DANIEL AND CONSUELO DAMIEN. HE
GRADUATED FROM BALDWIN PARK
HIGH SCHOOL IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX WHERE HE PLAYED BOTH
VARSITY BASEBALL AND FOOTBALL.
SHORTLY THERE AFTER GRADUATING
FROM HIGH SCHOOL HE OPENED THE
WIRELESS BUSINESS WITH HIS
BROTHER DANNY DANNY IN. THAT
LED HIM INTO THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY WHERE HE HAD A CAREER
AS A MANAGER FOR AT&T. ON JULY
TWENTY SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE HE MERRY GLORIA
HERNANDEZ. THEY RAISED THREE
CHILDREN. MANUAL ASHLEY AND
ALEXIS. TONY HAD A PASSION FOR
BARBECUING HE LOVES SPORTS AND
ENJOYED GOING ON TRIPS WITH HIS
FAMILY. HE ALWAYS MADE TIME TO
VISIT HIS MOM AND TAKE HER OUT
TO EAT AND SHOPPING ON THE
WEEKENDS. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
MOM CONSUELO WIFE GLORIA HIS
THREE CHILDREN. MANUAL ASHLEY
AND ALEXIS HIS BROTHERS CARLOS
DOWNEY SISTER CARMEN AND
SEVERAL NIECES NEPHEWS AND
COUSINS. HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS
CONTRACT CONTAGIOUS LAUGHTER IS
INFECTIOUS LOVE AND IS KIND AND
COMPASSIONATE SPIRIT. AND IT IS
MY GREAT PRIVILEGE TO STAND
HERE BEFORE THIS ASSEMBLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF ANTHONY
DAMIEN. THANK YOU MISS RUBIO.
MISTER ROBERTS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY TODAY OF
DOCTOR ME ON KIANA WHO PASSED
AWAY ON AUGUST EIGHTEENTH. WE
EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY FRIENDS AND TO THE
EXTENT A KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY TO WHOM HE WAS
DEVOTED HE WAS EIGHTY SEVEN
YEARS OF AGE DR HONG WAS BORN
IN SEOUL SOUTH KOREA AND
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
TO FURTHER HIS STUDIES HE
BECAME THE FIRST KOREAN PERSON
TO OBTAIN HIS BACHELORS IN
CHEMISTRY FROM UCLA IN NINETEEN
FIFTY NINE. DR HONG FOR
PERSONIFIED THE IMMIGRANT
SUCCESS STORY THROUGH HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND HIS GIVING
SPIRIT. HIS DAUGHTER CHRISTINE
HONG SAID HIS PHILOSOPHY WAS TO
SHARE ON. DOCTOR HAHN'S MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDE BUT ARE
NOT LIMITED TO. FOUNDING HIS
OWN COMPANY DURA COAT PRODUCTS
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX.
ESTABLISHING THE BRIGHT WORLD
M. AND NOW HONG FOUNDATION TO
PROVIDE VARIOUS OPPORTUNITIES
FOR KOREAN AMERICAN YOU. AND
RECEIVING AN HONORARY DOCTORATE
FROM LAST YEAR UNIVERSITY FOR
HIS HUMANITARIAN WORK AND
SERVING AS HEAD ELDER AT THE
LOMA LINDA KOREAN SEVENTH DAY
ADVENTIST CHURCH. HE
CONTRIBUTED TO ETHNIC STUDIES
PROGRAMS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE LOS SIERRA
RIVER UNIVERSITY AND UCLA. DR
HONG ALSO GAVE TWO MILLION TO
UCLA TO IN DOUBT TO FACULTY
CHAIRS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHEMISTRY AND BIOCHEMISTRY. DR
HANS PASSING INSPIRED NUMEROUS
HEARTFELT TRIBUTES AND ALL
PRAISE HIS GENEROSITY HIS
INTEGRITY AND WORK ETHIC I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURNED MR HONG'S.
MEMORY THANK YOU RESTAURANTS
STRUCTURE TWENTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS A GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF A DOCTOR YANKEE A HONG. THE
COMMUNITY HOME IS OVERCROWDED
DOG AS SOME EXEMPLARY FIGURE AS
SOMEONE OF THE A MOST OF
SUCCESS FOR A KOREAN AMERICAN
BUSINESSMAN AND THE END UP OF
THE BEST ROLE MODEL IDEA
KOREANS ARE AT THE HOME AND IN
CALIFORNIA. AS A FIRST
GENERATION THE KOREAN AMERICAN
DOCTOR HOME HAS BEEN DEEPLY
INVOLVED WITH THE PHILANTHROPIC
CIVILE CIVIC AND- CHARITABLE
RECALLS IS- IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY WITH
THE AIM OF- CULTIVATING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AMONG. IMMIGRANTS
AND- MARGINALIZED ARE YOU WITH.
DR MINDY HOME PERMITTED TO
HIMSELF TO PROMOTING COMMUNITY
HARMONY AFTER THE NINETEEN
NINETY TWO- CIVIL UNREST IN LOS
ANGELES BY ENSURING. ACTIVE
AND- SO STAY IN THE KOREAN
AMERICAN PARTICIPATION IN
POLITICS AND THE GOVERNMENT. DR
HOME HAS BEEN THE RECIPIENT OF
NUMEROUS AWARDS AND HONORS
INCLUDING. RECOGNITION NOT BY
YOURSELF OF KOREA AS THE
HIGHEST A CIVILIAN DISTINCTION
NATIONAL MEDAL OF HONOR BOGAN
MAHJONG IN. TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
AND- COMING BACK- MEDAL OF
HONOR FOR HIS- WORKED TOWARD
THE REUNIFICATION OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE. DR MINDY HOME AND TO HIS
WIFE LIVE SCORE WAS SO. HOW TO
SUPPORT A RANGE OF PROJECTS AND
INITIATIVES THE SURVEY AND THE
BENEFIT OF HUMANITY THROUGH
RESEARCH FUNDING SCHOLARSHIPS
ARE FOR STUDENTS SO FOR A
MINORITY OR DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS AND THE BACKING
COMMUNITY BASED THE ENDEAVOR.
DR MINDY HOMES TO WIFE OF
PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST. TWENTY
ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. SINCE
THEN A DOCTOR HOME DEDICATED
HIMSELF TO HONOR HIM AND HIS
WIFE SO VISION OF A PUBLIC
SERVICE THROUGH THERE ARE MNL
HOME FOUNDATION AND HAS THE
FINAL CHAPTER OF LIFE. CREAN
AMERICANS SEE DOCUMENT YOU HOME
AS A PIONEER FOR THE ESTEEM OF
A KOREAN AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE
USA. IS A MEMORY ON SERVICE-
ALL WILL BE SHORTLY TAKEN PLACE
OF THIS EVENING AND IS A
FUNERAL SERVICE WILL BE- HORDES
THE WOULD BE HOUSE BILL
TOMORROW. IT IS A TRUE HONOR TO
OR JOAN DR HOMES. MEMORY TODAY
AS WE- OR JUNE IT IS SO-
ASSEMBLY SESSION ON THIS
WONDERFUL IN COURT AND THE
INCREDIBLE HUSBAND AND THE
FATHER AND THE LEADER OF THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AFTER CHINA'S QUICK SILVA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE CENTER OF
THE SCRIPTS OF A- MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAME SUGGESTS
WE PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST RETURNING MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS RULES WILL MEET
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION IN
ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY SEPTEMBER THIRD FLOOR
SESSION AT NINE AM MEMBERS WE
WILL CONVENE TOMORROW MORNING
AT NINE AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMOVED REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAINED ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I
AM READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN. MISTER BENNETT
MOVEMENT GONZALEZ SECOND FOR
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL FRIDAY SEPTEMBER THIRD AT
NINE AM OR- CALL HAS ALREADY
BEEN LIFTED. THANK YOU. IF YOU
START RIGHT ARE WE READY. HEY
CHANGE AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN I
IT'S NOT VOTING. SORRY. WHAT
CHANGED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ SENATE BILL. ONE
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN I TO
NOT VOTED.
BURKE CHANGE
CERVANTES FILE ITEM ONE
NINETEEN S. B. FIVE TEN I DO
NOT VOTING. CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES SENATE BILL
FIVE TEN I TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN GARCIA VOTE
CHANGE ON SB FORTY FOUR I'M NOT
VOTING TO AYE. BUT CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR NOT
VOTING T<c.cyan>.</c>